the use of data analytics has been
rapidly growing with companies looking
to generate insights and drive their
business with the help of data hey
everyone welcome to this full course
video on data analytics in this video we
will learn data analytics from scratch
and analyze data using python in our
programming language we have our
experience instructors richard avijit
akshata and shruti who will help you
learn data analytics in detail
in this video you will learn what is
data analytics and why data analytics
will look at the different types of data
analytics and see the various
applications of data analytics
then you will understand a case study
and perform analysis of data using
python nr
after that
we will see the top 10 data analysis
tools and understand the difference
between a data scientist and a data
analyst
finally we look at the top interview
questions that will help you crack a
data analyst interview we will learn all
of these under five hours
over to richard now
welcome to data analytics using python
my name is richard kirschner with the
simply learn team that's
www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead
so we're going to cover data analytics
with python we're going to go over what
is data analytics applications of data
analytics types of data analytics
data analytics process steps why python
for data analytics and then we'll dive
into use case demo so you can actually
see some script and actually see what it
looks like in the python code
what is data analytics
data analytics is a process of exploring
and analyzing large data sets to make
predictions and help data-driven
decision-making now the definition of
large datasets keeps changing and so
this can range
really from just about anything to
anything
but usually in today's world we're
talking significantly larger amounts of
data that you can't just glance at and
try to figure it out yourself and the
two steps are analyze the data and then
make decisions based on the data
applications of data analytics
now the sky's the limit on this in
today's world almost every business act
of life your music on your spotify are
driven by data analytics
but some of the big players when you go
in their job hunting are going to be
your fraud analysis if you want to go
make a lot of money and you're good at
it and you like dealing with numbers
go join the banks and track down the
criminals who are stealing money it's a
lot of you know it's a big thing to
protect credit cards protect sales
purchases bad checks any of those things
when you can track them down is huge
healthcare exploding
there's everything from trying to find
cures for
the covet virus or any of the viruses
out there
using your cell phone to diagnose
different ailments
that way you don't have to go and see
the doctor you can actually just go in
there and take a picture of the funky
growth on your arm hopefully it's not
too big
and then they send it in there and the
data analytics goes in and looks at it
and says oh this is what this is this is
a professional you need to go see or
don't need to see
and that's just one aspect of health
care the database is being generated by
health care and getting the right
doctors and helping the doctors analyze
whether something is
benign or malignant if it's cancerous
all those things are now part of the
ongoing health care growth in data
analytics
inventory management
think one of those huge warehouses where
they're shipping out all the goods
how do you inventory that in such a way
so that
you maximize the stuff that's being
purchased the most near the entrance and
all the other stuff towards the back or
even pre-ship it
so it's huge to be able to inventory the
manager inventory and pretty soon
they'll just have a drone come in there
and start picking up some of those boxes
and move them around also
deliver your logistics again this goes
from getting from point a to point b
you can combine it with our inventory so
you pre-ship stuff if you know a certain
area is more likely to purchase it how
do you get it the delivery to the most
destinations the quickest in the short
amount of time and then they even
pre-stacked the trucks going out and
that's all done with data analytics how
do we stack all that stuff so it comes
out in the right order
targeted marketing
huge industry any kind of marketing
whether you're generating uh the right
content for the marketing who are you
targeting with that marketing
researching the people what they want so
you know what products to market out
there all those things are huge
and these are just a few examples you
can probably go way beyond this from
tracking forest fires
to astrology and studying the stars all
of this is part of data analytics now
and plays a huge role in all these
different areas
city planning is another one
you know you can see a nice organized
city like this one where you can get in
and out of the neighborhoods if you're a
fire truck
police officers need to be able to get
in and out you want your tourists to be
able to come in you still want the place
to look nice and you have the right
commercial development the right
industrial development like enough
residents for people to stay all those
things are part of your city planning
again huge in data analytics
so sky's the limit on what you use it
for let's take a look at types of data
analytics
and this can be broken up in so many
ways but we're going to start with
looking at the most basic questions
that you're going to be asking in data
analytics and the first one is you want
descriptive analytics what has happened
hindsight
how many cells per call ratio coming out
of the call center
if we have 500 tourists in a forest and
you have a certain temperature how many
fires were started how many times did
the police have to show up to certain
houses
all that's descriptive
the next one is predictive predictive
analytics is what will happen next we
want to predict
this is great if you have a ice cream
store and you want to predict how many
people to work at the ice cream store in
a certain day based on the temperature
coming up in the time of the year
and then one of the biggest growing and
most important parts of the industry is
now prescriptive analytics and you can
think of that as combining the first two
we have descriptive and we have
predictive then you get
pre-scriptive analytics
how can we make it happen foresight what
can we change to make this work better
in all the industries we looked at
before we can start asking questions
especially in city development there's a
good one
if we want to have our city generate
more income
and we want that income to be commercial
based
what kind of commercial buildings do we
need to build in that area that are
going to bring people over do we need
huge warehouse sales costco sales
buildings or do we need little mom pod
joints that are going to bring in
people from the country to come shop
there or do you want an industrial setup
what do you need to bring that industry
in there is our car industry available
in that area
if it's not a car industry what other
industries are in that area all those
things are prescriptive we're guessing
we're guessing what can we do to fix it
what can we do to fix crime in area with
education what kind of education are we
going to use
to help people understand what's going
on so that we lower the rate of crime
and we help our communities grow better
that's all prescriptive it's all
guessing we want foresight into how can
we make it happen how can we make this
better
and we really can't not go into enough
detail on these three because a lot of
people stumble on this when they come in
and are doing analytics whether you're
the manager
shareholder or the data scientist coming
in you really need to understand the
descriptive analytics where you're
studying the total units of furniture
sold and the profit that was made in the
past
here we go into predictive analytics
predicting the total units that would
sell and the profit we can expect in the
future
gear up for how many employees we need
how much money we're going to make
and prescriptive analytics finding ways
to improve the sales and the profit so
we can sell maybe a different kind of
furniture we're going to guess at what
the area is looking for and how that
marketing is going to change
data analytics process steps
so let's take a look at some of the
basic processing and what that looks
like when you're working with this data
so there's five basic steps uh the five
steps of processing and this changes and
there's a lot of things that go on when
they talk about
agile programming
the whole concept of agile is you take
some kind of framework like this
and then you build on it depending on
what your business needs
so the first step is data collection
and usually with a large company you
might have somebody who
is responsible for the database
management uh you may have another one
where they're pulling apis and they're
pulling data off of maybe the census
bureau
maybe something very very
specific domain specific so if you're
analyzing cancerous growths and how to
understand them then the data collection
is going to be those measurements they
take from the mri or it might be even
the mri images they've used those also
so there's a lot of things with data
collection and how to
control that and make sure it has what
you need and is clean and you don't have
miss information coming in
once you have the data collected there's
a data preparation
so stage two is we take that data and we
format it into something we can use
probably one of the biggest formats that
you see is when you're processing text
how do you process text
well you use what they call a one hot
encoder and each word is represented uh
by a yes no kind of setup so it'd be
like a long array of bits
that's one way to prepare it and so you
know bit number one is the bit number
two is has or whatever it is
other preparations might be if you're
using neural networks you might be
taking integers or float numbers and
converting them to a value between zero
and one
that way you don't have one of them
creating a bias in there so there's a
lot of different things that go into
data preparation
that is eighty percent of data science
so we talk about the data analytics
which is a little bit more on the math
side and they usually say talk about a
data scientist kind of being the overall
preparer of this stuff you're going to
spend 80 percent of your data
preparation
data exploration
that's the fun part this is where you're
exploring things uh and it is
maybe 10 to 15 percent of what you do
with the data you spend with the data
exploration it is probably uh the most
important step
because this is where you got to start
asking questions
if you ask your questions wrong you're
going to get some wrong information
if you're working with a company and
they want to know the marketing values
then you really got to focus on hey how
do we generate money for this company or
fraud how do we lower the fraud rate
while still generating a profit
four
data modeling this is where we start
actually getting into the data code
which model to use
that predicts what's going to happen
and then result interpretation we want
to be able to interpret those results
usually see that in your matplot library
where you create nice beautiful images
so it shows up on their dashboard for
the marketing
manager or for the ceo so they can take
a quick look and say hey i can see
what's going on there you want to reduce
it to something they can easily read
they don't want to hear the scientific
terms they want to see something they
can use
and we'll talk about that a little bit
more and we start looking at some of
this in a
demo since this is data analysis with
python
we've got to ask the question why python
for data analytics i mean there's c plus
there's java there's
dot net from microsoft why do people go
to python for it
so the number of reasons one it's easy
to learn with simple syntax
you don't have a very high typeset like
you do in java and other coding so it
allows you to kind of
be a little lazy in your programming
that doesn't mean that it can't be set
that way and that you don't have to be
careful it just means you can spin up a
code much quicker in python the same
amount of code to do something in python
a lot of times is one two or three or
four lines
where when i did the same thing say in
java i found myself with 10 12 13 20
lines depending on what it was
it's very scalable and flexible
so there's our flexibility because you
can do a lot with it and you can easily
scale it up you can go from something on
your machine
to using
pi spark under the spark environment and
spread that across hundreds if not
thousands of servers across terabytes of
data or petabytes of data so it's very
scalable
there's a huge collection of libraries
this one's always interesting because
java has a huge collection of libraries
c has a huge collection of libraries dot
net does and they're always in
competition to get those libraries out
scala for your spark
all those have huge collections of
libraries this is always changing
but because python's open source you
almost always have easy to access
libraries that anybody can use you don't
have to go check your licensing and have
special licensing like you do in some
packages
graphics and visualization they have a
really powerful package for that so it
makes it easy to create nice displays
for people to read
and community support because python is
open source it has a huge community that
supports it you can do a quick google
and probably find a solution for almost
anything you're working on
python libraries let's bring it together
we have data analytics and we have
python so when we're talking data
analytics we're talking python libraries
for data analytics
and the big five players are numpy
pandas matplot library scipy which is
going to be in the background so we're
not going to talk too much about the
scientific formulas inside pi and psi
kit
so numpy supports n-dimensional arrays
provides numerical computing tools
useful for linear algebra and fourier
transform
and you can think of this as just a grid
of numbers
and you can even have a grid inside a
grid
or data it's not even numbers because
you can also put words and characters
and just about anything into that array
but you can think of a grid and then you
can have a grid inside a grid and you
end up with a nice three-dimensional
array
if you want to talk three-dimensional
array you can think of images you have
your three channels of color four if you
have an alpha and then you have your x y
coordinates for the image we're looking
at so you can go x y and then what are
the three channels to generate that
color
and numpy isn't restricted to three
dimensions you could imagine
watching a movie well now you have your
movie clips and they each have their x
number of frames and each of those
frames have
x number of x y coordinates for the
pictures in each frame and then you have
your three dimensions for the colors
so numpy is just a great way to work
with in-dimensional arrays
now closely with numpy is pandas
useful for handling missing data perform
mathematical operations provides
functions to manipulate data
pandas is becoming huge because it is
basically a data frame and if you're
working with big data and you're working
in spark or any of the other major
packages out there you realize that the
data frame is very central to a lot of
that and you can look at it as a excel
spreadsheet you have your columns you
have your rows and or indexes and
you can do all kinds of different
manipulations of the data within
including filling in missing data which
is a big thing when you're dealing with
large
pools or lakes of data where they might
be collected differently from different
locations
and matplot library
we did kick over the sci pi which is a
lot of mathematical computations which
usually runs in the background of the
for of numpy and pandas although you do
use them they're useful for a lot of
other things in there but the matplot
library that's the final part that's
what you want to show people and this is
your plotting library in python several
toolkits extend matplot library
functionality
there's like a hundred different
toolkits to extend matplot library which
range from
how to properly display star
constellations from astronomy there's a
very specific one built just for that
all the way to some very generic ones
we'll actually add seaborne in when we
do the labs in a minute several toolkits
extend map plot library functionality
and it creates interactive visualization
so there's all kinds of cool things you
can do as far as just displaying graphs
and there's even some that you can
create interactive graphs we won't do
the interactive graphs but you'll see
you'll get a
pretty good grasp of some of the
different things you can do in matplot
library
jump over to the demo which is my
favorite roll up our sleeves and get our
hands in on what we're doing
now there's a lot of options when we're
dealing with python uh you can use pie
charm is a really popular one
and you'll see this all over the place
so it's one of the main ones that's out
there and there's a lot of other ones i
used to use netbeans which is kind of
lost favor
don't even have it installed on my new
computer
but the most popular one right now for
data science now pycharm is really
popular for python general development
for data science we usually go to
jupiter notebook or anaconda and we're
going to jump into anaconda because
that's my favorite one to go to because
it has a lot of external tools for us
we're not going to dig into those but we
will pop in there so you can see what it
looks like so
with anaconda we have our jupiter lab we
have our
notebook
these are identical jupiter lab is an
upgrade to the notebooks with multiple
tabs that's all it is and we'll be using
the notebook and you can see that
pycharm is so popular with
python that we even have highlighted
here in anaconda as part of the setup
jupiter notebook can also be a
stand-alone so we're actually going to
be running jupiter notebook
and then you have your different
environments
i have we're going to be under main pi
36 there's a root one and i usually
label it pi 3 6 the reason is is
currently as of writing this tensorflow
only works in three six and not in three
seven or three eight for doing neural
networks
but you can actually have multiple
environments which is nice there they
separate the kernel so it helps protect
your computer when you're doing
development and this is just a great way
to do a display or a demo
especially if you're looking for that
job pull up your laptop open it up or if
you're doing a meeting get it broadcast
up to the big screen so that the ceo can
see what you're looking at
and when we launch the notebook it
actually opens up a file browser in
whatever web browser you have this
happens to be chrome
and then you can just go under new
there's a lot of different options
depending what you have installed
python3
and this just creates an untitled
version of this and you can see here i'm
actually in a simply learn folder for
other work i've done for simplylearn
and that's where i save all my stuff and
i can browse through other folders
making it real easy to jump from one
project to another
and under here we'll go ahead and change
the name of this and we'll go ahead and
rename it
data analytics
data analytics just so i can remember
what i was doing
which is probably about 50 of the
folders in here or files in here right
now
so let's go ahead and jump in there and
take a look at some of these different
tools that we were looking at
and as we go through the demo let's
start with the numpy
the least visually exciting and i'm
going to zoom in here so you can see
what we're doing
and the first thing we want to do is
import numpy
and we'll import it as np that is the
most common numpy terminology
and let's go ahead and change the view
so we also have the line numbers
i don't know why we probably won't need
them but make it for easy reference
and then we'll create a one dimensional
array we'll just call this array1
and it equals np.array and you put your
array information in here
in this case we'll spell it out
you can actually do like a range in
other ways there's lots of ways to
generate these arrays but we'll just do
one two three so three integers
and if we print
our array one
we can go ahead and run this
and you can see right here prints one
two three you can see why this is a
really nice interface to show other
people what you're doing uh with the
jupiter notebook
so this is the basic we've created an
array this is a one dimensional array
and then the array is one two three
one of the nice things about the jupiter
notebook is whatever ran in this first
setup
is still running it's still in the
kernel so it still has the numpy
imported as np and it still has our
variable
arr1 for array one equal to np array of
one two three
so when we go to the next cell
we can check the type of the array we're
just gonna print
we say hey what's what is this
setup in here and we want type
and then we want what is the type of
array one let's go ahead and run that
and it says class numpy nd array so it's
its own class that's all we're doing is
checking to see what that class is
and if you look at the array class uh
probably the biggest thing you do
i don't know how many times i find
myself doing this
because i forget what i'm working on and
i forget i'm working with a
three-dimensional or four-dimensional
array uh and i have to reformat somehow
so it works with whatever other things i
have and so we do the array shape the
array shape is just three because it has
three members and it's a one-dimensional
array that's all that is
and with the numpy array we can easily
access
stick with the print statement
if you actually put a variable in
jupiter notebook and it's the last one
in the cell
it will be the same as a print statement
so if i do this where array one of two
is the same as doing print
array of two that's those are identical
statements in our jupiter notebook
we'll go and stick with the print on
this one
and it's three so there's our print
space two and we have zero one two
two equals three we can easily change
that so we have array one of place two
equals 5
and then if we print our array 1
you can see right down here when it
comes out it's 1 2 and 5.
and there i left the print statement off
because it's the last variable in the
list it'll always print the variable if
you just put it in like that
that's a jupiter notebook thing don't do
that in pycharm i've forgotten before
doing a demo
and we talked about multiple dimensions
so we'll do an array two dimensional
array
and this is again a numpy array
and in the numpy array
we need our first dimension we'll do one
two three
and our
second dimension uh three four five and
you can see right here that when we hit
the uh
we'll do this we'll just do array two
and we can run that and there's our
array two one two three three four five
we can also do array two
of
uh one
and then we can do let's do zero it
doesn't really matter which one actually
do two there we go
and if i run this it'll print out five
because here we are this is zero
zero one two three is under zero row
three four five is on our one row and we
start with zero
and then the two zero one two goes to
the five
and then maybe we forgot what we were
working with so we'll go do array two
dot
shape and if we do array two of shape
we'll go and run that
we'll see we have two rows and each row
has three elements a two dimensional
array two three if you looked up here
when we did it before it just had three
comma nothing when you have a single
entity it always saves it as a tuple
with a blank space
but you can see right here we have two
comma three
and if you remember from up here we just
did this array 2 of let's go what is it
comma 2.
we run that we get the 5.
you can also count backwards this is
kind of fun
and you'll see i just kind of switch
something on you because you can also do
one comma two to get to the same spot
now two is the last
one zero one two it's the last one in
there we can count backwards and do
minus one and if we run this we get the
same answer whether we count it as
let's go back up here whether we count
this as 0 1 2
or we count backwards as minus 1 minus 2
minus 3. and you can see that if i
change this minus 1 to a minus 2 and run
that
i get 4 which is going backwards minus 1
minus 2.
so there's a lot of different ways to
reference what we're working on inside
the numpy array
it's really a cool tool it's got a lot
of things you can do with it
and we talked about the fact that it can
also hold things that are not values and
we'll call this array s for strings
equals np.array
put our setup in there brackets
and let's go
china
um
india
usa
uh mexico
it doesn't matter we can make whatever
we want on here
and if we print that out
and we run this you can see that we get
another numpy of ray china india usa
mexico it even gives us our d type of a
u6
and a lot of times when you're messing
with data we'll call this array r for
range
just to kind of keep it uniform
in p dot
a range
so this is a command inside numpy to
create a range of numbers
and if you're testing data maybe you
want maybe you have equal time
increments that are spaced a certain
point apart
but in this case we're just going to do
integers
and we're going to do
a setup from 0 20 skipping every other
one
and we'll print it out and see what that
looks like
and you can see here we have 0 2 4 6 8
10 12 14 16 18 like you expected it
skips every one
and just a quick note
there's no 20 on here uh why well this
starts at 0
and counts up to 20. so if you're used
to another language where explicitly
says uh less than or less than equal to
20 like for x equals zero
x plus plus
uh x is less than 20. that's what this
is it just assumes x is less than 20 on
here
and if we want to create a very uniform
set you know 0 2 4 6 what happens if i
want to create numbers
from 0 to 10 but i need 20 increments in
there we can do that with line space so
we can create
an r uh we'll call this l
equals i don't think we'll actually use
any of this again so i don't know why
i'm creating unique identifiers for it
but we'll do np
lin space
and we're going to do 0
to 10 or 0 to 9 remember it doesn't it
goes up to 10.
and then we want to let's say we have 20
different um
increments in there so we're creating a
we have a data set and we know it's over
a certain time period and we need to
divide that time period by 20 and it
happens to just have 10 pieces in it
and here we go you can see right here we
have 20 or has 20 pieces in it but it's
over 10 years we got divided in the
middle and you can see it does it goes
0.52 remember
yeah others are 10 on the end so it goes
up to 10.
uh and then we can also do random
there's np.random
if you're doing neural networks
usually you start it by seating it with
random numbers
and we'll just do np.random
and we'll just call this array
we'll stop giving it unique numbers
we'll print that one out and run it
and you can see we have random numbers
they are zero to one so you'll see that
all these numbers are under one and you
can
easily alter that by multiplying them
out or something like that if you wanna
do like zero to a hundred
you can also round them up if it's
integer zero to a hundred there's all
kinds of things you can do but generates
a random float between 0 and 1.
and you have a couple options you could
reshape that
or you can just generate them
in
whatever shape you want and so we can
see here
we did 3 and 4 and so you can see three
rows by four variables
same thing as doing a reshape of 12
variables to three and four
and if you're going to do that you might
need an empty data set
i have had this come up many times
or i need to start off with zero
and i don't know you know because i'm
going to be adding stuff in there or it
might be zero and one where one is uh if
you're removing the background of an
image you might want the background is
zero and then you figure out where the
image is and you set all those boxes to
one and you create a mask so creating
masks over images is really big and
doing that with a numpy array of zero
and we can also uh
give it a space
and we'll just do this all in one shot
this time
and we'll do the same thing like we did
before
zeros and in this case we'll do uh two
comma three and so when we run this
i forgot the asterisks around it i knew
it was forgetting something there we go
so when we run this
you can see here we have our ten zeros
in a row
and maybe this is a mask for an image
and so it has
two rows of three digits in it so it's a
very small image a little tiny pixel
and maybe you're looking to do something
the opposite way
instead of creating a mask of zeros and
filling in with ones
maybe you want to create a mask of ones
and fill them in with zeros and we'll
just do
just like we did before with the three
comma four
and when we run this you'll see it's all
ones and we could even do this even
maybe we'll do it this way let's do
10 by 10 icon and then you have your
three colors
so creates quite a large array there for
doing pictures and stuff like that when
you add that third dimension in
if we take that off it's a little bit
easier to see
uh we'll do 10 again
and you can easily see how we have 10
rows of 10 ones
and you can also do something like
create an array
and we'll do 0
1 2
and then in this array
we actually print it right out
we want a repeat so you can actually do
a repeat
of the array and maybe you need this
array
let's repeat it three times
so there's our repeat of an array repeat
three times
and if we run this
you'll see we have zero zero zero one
one one two 2 2.
and whenever i think of a repeat i don't
really think of repeating being the
first digit 3 times the second digit i
really always think of it as
0 1 2 0 1 2 0 1 2. it catches me every
time
but the actual code for that one
is going to be tile
and again if we do a range 3
and we run this
you can see how you can generate 1 0 1 2
0 1 2 0 1 2.
and if you're dealing with
an identity matrix
we can do that also if you're big on
you're doing your matrixes
and we'll just identity
i guess we'll go ahead and spell it out
today may tricks
and the command we're looking for is um
i e y e and we'll do three and then
we'll just go ahead and print this out
there we go there's our identity matrix
and it comes out by a three by three
array because there's our matrix
and then it puts the ones down the
middle and for doing your different
matrix math
and we can manipulate that a little bit
too
we talk about
matrixes
we might not want ones across the middle
in which case we now have
the diagonal so we can do an np dot
diagonal
and we do a diagonal let's put in the
one two three four five and when we run
this
again this generates a value and by just
putting that value in there's the same
as putting print around it or putting
array equals and then print array and
you can see it generates a diagonal one
two three four five and there's your
your beginning of your matrix array for
working with matrixes
and we can actually go in reverse let's
create an array
equals remember our random
dot random.random and we'll do a five by
five array uh oops there we go
five by five
and just so you can see what that looks
like
helps if i don't miss type the numbers
which in this case i just need to take
out the brackets
and there you go you have your your five
by five array set up in there and we can
now because we're working with matrixes
we might want to do this in reverse and
extract the diagonals which would be the
0.79 the 0.678 and so on
and we simply type in
np.diagonal
we put our array in there
and this will of course print it out
because it returns it as a variable and
you can see here here's our diagonal
going across from our matrix
and we did talk about shape earlier if
you remember you can do
print the shape out you can also do the
dimensions
so in dimensions very similar to shape
it comes out and just has two dimensions
we can also look at the size so if we do
size on here
we can run that and you can see has a
size of 25 two dimensions and of course
five by five
and that was from the shape from earlier
that we looked at
there's our five by five shape
and if you remember earlier we did
random well you can also do
random i talked a little bit about
manipulating zero to one and how you can
get different answers you can also do
straight for the integer part and we'll
do minus uh ten
to ten
four
and so we're going to
generate random integers between minus
10 to 10. uh we're going to generate
four of those and so when we run that we
have 7 minus 3 minus 6 minus 3.
they're all between minus 10 and 10 and
there's four of them
and now we jump into some of the
functionality of arrays which is really
great because this is where they come in
here's your array and you can add 10 to
it and if i run this
there takes my original array from up
here
with the integers and adds 10 to all of
those values so now we have oh this is
the decimal that's right this is a
random decimal i had stored an array
but this takes a random decimal the
random numbers i had from 0 to 1 and
adds 10 to them and we can just as
easily do
minus 10
we could even do
times 2
and we could do divide by 2
and it would take that
random number we generated and cut in
half so now all these numbers are under
0.5
another way you can
change the numbers to what you need on
there
and as you dig deeper into numpy we can
also do exponential so as an exponential
function
which would generate some interesting
numbers off of the random
so we're taking them to the power i
don't even remember what the original
numbers in the um
array were because we did the random
numbers up there here's our original
numbers and if you
build an exponential on there uh this is
where you get e to the x on this and
just like you can do e to the x
you can also do the log so if you're
doing logarithmic functions
that reinforce learning you might be
doing some kind of log setup on there
and you can see the logarithmic of these
different ray numbers
and if you're working with log base 2
you can do you can just change it in
there in p log 2.
you have to look it up because this is
not log 1 two three four five um it is
log and log two uh so just a quick note
that's not a variable going in that is
an actual command
there's a number of them in there and
you'll have to go look and see what the
documentation is but you can also do log
10. so here's log value 10.
some other really cool functions you can
do with this is your sign
so we can take a sine value of all of
our different values in there
and if you have sine you of course have
cosine
we can run that
so here's the cosine of those and if
you're doing activations in your numpy
array and you're doing a tangent
activation
there's your tangent for that
and the tangent activation is actually
uh from
neural networks that's one of the ways
you can activate it because it forms a
nice
curve between uh from whether you're
generating one to negative one uh with
some discrepancy in the middle
just jumping a little bit in there into
neural networks
and then we get into let me just put the
array back out there so that we can see
it
while we're doing this as we're getting
into this you can also sum the values so
we have np sum
and you can do a summation of all the
values in this array and you'll see that
if you added all these together they'd
equal
12.519 so on i don't know what the whole
setup is in there
but you can see right here the the
summation of this
one of the things you can also do is by
axes so we could do axes equals zero
and if we run the summation of the axis
equals zero
and you can think of that
in numpy
as the rows so that would be
or
you can think of that in numpy as being
the columns we're summing these columns
going across
and you can also change this to one
and now we're summing the rows
and so that is the summation of this row
and so forth and so forth going down
and maybe you don't need to
know the summation maybe what you're
looking for is the minimum
so here's our minimal you're looking for
and this comes up a lot because you have
like your errors we want to find the
minimal error inside of this array
and just like
the other one we can do axes equals 0.
and you can see here 0.0645 is the
smallest number in this first column is
0.0645 and so on
and if you have a minimum well you might
also want to know the max maybe we're
looking for the maximum profit
and here we go you can see maximum 0.79
is the maximum on this first column
and
just like we did before you can change
this to a 1
on axis you can take the axis out of
here and just find the max value for the
whole array and the max value in here
was 0.8344 so on so on
and since we're talking data analytics
we want to go ahead and look at the mean
pretty much the same as the average this
is the mean across the whole thing
and just like we did before we could
also do axes equals zero
and then you'll see this is the mean of
this axes and so on
and we have mean
we might want to know the median
and there's our median our most common
numbers
if we have median we might want to know
the standard deviation
or if we have the average a lot of times
you do the means and the standard
deviation
we can run that and there's our standard
deviations along the axis we can also do
it across the whole array
uh if we're going to do standard
deviations there's also
variance
which is your var
and there's our variance across the
different levels
and so if we looked at that we looked at
variance we looked at standard deviation
the median and the means
there's more but those are the most
common ones used with data analytics and
then going through your data and
figuring out
what you're going to present to the
shareholders
and some other things we can do is we
can actually take slices
you'll hear that terminology
and a slice might be um like we have a
five by five array but maybe we don't
want the whole array maybe we want uh
from one on we don't want the zero in
there so we got up to four and maybe on
the second part we just want
two
to row three and see this notation right
here says
one to the end and if we run this you
can see how that generates a single row
to the end and then row two and three
now remember it doesn't include three
that's why we only get the one column so
if you wanted two and three you would
need to go ahead and go two to four so
it goes up to four
we could also do this in reverse just
like we learned earlier we can go minus
one whoops
and when we go to minus one
it's the same thing because we have zero
one two three four this is the same
thing as two to four it goes two to the
last one
also very common with arrays is you're
going to want to sort them so we still
have our array up here that we randomly
generated and we might want to
sort it and we'll go and throw an axis
back in there
axes equals one if we run this
you can see from the axes that it sorts
it
the point two being the lowest value to
the highest value by the row
we can also change this of course to
axis 0
if you're sorting it by column so maybe
your values are based on columns
and then of course you can do the whole
array
and we can sort that i don't usually do
that but you know i guess sometimes you
might that might come up
and so you can see right here we have a
nice sorted array
uh something else let's just go ahead
and reprint our array so we can look at
it again starting to get too many boxes
up there
something else you can do with an array
is we can take and transpose it
this comes up more than you would think
when you transpose it you'll see that
the rows and the column are transposed
so where
0.79.57 0.064
is a column
now we've switched it and we have
0.79.42
as the index
you can see this really more dramatic if
we take a slice
and we'll just do a slice of the first
couple
and then we'll just do all the other
the full rows and if we run this you can
see how it comes up a little bit
different and we'll just do the same
slice up here so you can see how those
two look next to each other
there we go there's our slice run
and so you can see the slice comes up
and it has a one two three four five
columns now we have one two three four
five rows and three columns versus three
rows
and the original version when they first
started putting this
together
was a function so the original version
was transpose and this still works you
can still see it generates the same
value as just a capital t
so many times we flip this data because
we'll have an x y value or we'll have an
image or something like that and it's
being read one way into the next process
and the next one needs it the opposite
so this actually happens a lot you need
to know how to transpose the data really
quick
and we can go ahead oh let's just take
here's our transpose we'll just stick
with the transpose on here
and instead of doing it this way we
might need to do something called
flattening
why would you flatten your data
if this is an array going into a neural
network you might want to send it in as
one set of values instead of two rows
and you can see here is all the values
as a single array it just flattens it
down into one array
so we covered our scientific means
transpose median
some different variations on here
some of the other things we want to do
is what happens if we want to append to
our array
so let's create a new array
i'm getting tired of looking at the same
set of random numbers we generated
earlier
um so we'll go ahead and create a new
array here something a little simpler so
it's easier to see what we're doing
and four five six seven eight
uh that's good enough i'll just do four
five six seven eight
and if we print this array
there it is four five six seven eight
and we might wanna append something to
the array so we have our array we need
to extend it
you've got to be very careful about
appending things to your array and
there's a number of reasons for that
one
is run time because of the way the numpy
ray is set up
a lot of times you build your data and
then push it into the numpy array
instead of continually adding on to
the array
and then it also usually it
automatically generates a copy for
protecting your data so there's a lot of
reasons to be careful about appending
this way but you can certainly do it
and we can just take our array we're
going to create a new array array one
and if we print array one and we append
eight to it
you'll see four five six seven and then
there's our eight appended onto the end
and if you want to append something to
an array
you'd probably also want to whoops
array 1. let's try that again there we
go now we have the 8 appended on to the
end so you can see four five six seven
eight and then we pinned it another
eight on there
and if you're going to append something
you might want to
go ahead and insert instead of appending
it might be you need to keep a certain
order and we can do the same thing we do
our array
and we're going to pin
or
insert
at the beginning and let's go ahead and
one two three one two three
and we go ahead and print our array two
we run it and you can see one two three
a pin is inserted at the beginning
uh inserts a lot more powerful and that
you can put it anywhere in the array we
can move it to the one spot and there we
go one two three
we can do a minus one
just for fun and you'll see it comes up
one two three and we're counting
backwards by one
i imagine do a minus zero
and run this and it turns out that minus
0 puts it back at the beginning because
that's why it registers a 0 just takes a
minus sign off
and just like we add numbers on we might
want to delete numbers
and so
let's do an np dot delete
well let's let's keep it a little bit
make it a little easy here um to watch
we'll go ahead and create an array three
and we'll do np
delete
and we're just working with array
uh two
and we want to do is delete zero space
uh so if you look at this here's our
array two our raid two starts with one
and when we delete the space on here
and print that out uh we deleted the one
right out of there
and we can also do something like this
where we can do it as a slice
and we can do let's do one comma three
and if we run one comma three you'll see
we've deleted the one space
and the three space out which deleted
our two and four
now keep in mind when you're messing
with adding lines and deleting lines
uh you have to be really careful because
there's a time element involved
as far as where the date is coming from
and it's really easy to delete the wrong
data and corrupt what you're working on
or to insert stuff where you don't want
it
so it's always a warning when we talk
about manipulating numpy arrays
and just like anything else we're doing
uh we'll create a array c
which equals we'll just do our
our numpy array that we just created our
number array three
and we can do copy so you can make a
copy of it
maybe you want to protect your original
data or
maybe you're making a mask and so you
copy the array and then the new array
make all these alterations and change it
from values to zero to one
to mask over the first one and of course
we if we do um array c since it equals a
copy of
uh array three it's the same thing one
three five six seven eight
and now we're getting into uh combine
and split arrays i end up doing a lot of
this
and i don't know how many times i end up
fiddling with this and having a mess
so
but but you do it a lot you know you
combine your arrays you split them you
might need one set of data for one thing
another set of data for the other
so let's go ahead and create two arrays
array one or a two
and i want you to note
in the terminology we're gonna look for
is concatenate what that means is we're
gonna take
we'll call this a raycat i like a raycat
there we go
our array cat
our concatenated array
we're taking array one and two and it's
very important to really pay attention
to your axes and your counts i can't
merge two arrays that have like the if
their axes are messed up and i'm merging
on axis zero
it's going to give me an error and i'll
have to reshape them so you've got to
make sure that whatever you're
concatenating together works
and what that means
as you can see here we have one two
three four one two three four and then
five six seven eight five six seven
eight along the zero axes
these each are four values
so it's a two by four value and if we go
ahead and switch this to one you can see
how this flips it a little bit so now we
have one two three four five six seven
eight
it's interesting that we chose that one
if i did something like this
where this is now
there we go
and we concatenate it
run this and it gives me an answer okay
because i have 2 by 2 and i'm using axes
1. but if i switch this to axis 0 where
now it's got 3 and 5
it gives me an error so you got to be
really careful on that to make sure that
your whatever axes you are putting
together that they match
so like i said this one oops x is one
axis one has two entities and since
we're going on axes one or by row you
can see that it lets it uh merge it
right onto the end there
and you could imagine this if this was a
xy plot of value or the x value going in
and the predicted y value coming out and
then you have another prediction and you
want to combine them this works really
easy for that
and we'll go back and let's just put
this back to where we had it
oops i forgot how many changes i made
there we go
i'll just put it oops i messed up in my
concatenation order here
there we go
okay so you can see that we went through
the different concatenation axes is
really important when you're doing your
concatenation values on here
and we'll switch this back to one just
because i like the looks of that better
there we go two rows
now there are other commands in here um
so we can do
cap v
equals npv
v stack
this is nothing more than your
concatenation
but instead we don't have to put the
axes in there because it's v stands for
vertical and so if we print out
cat
v and we run this
you can see we get the one two three
four one two three four and that would
be the same as making this axis zero for
vertical stack
and if you're going to have a vertical
stack
you can also have an h stack
so if we change this to from v stack to
oops here we go h stack
and we'll just change this from cat to
cat
and i run this
it's the same as doing axis zero the
process is identical in the background
this is like a legacy setup your v stack
and your h stack
most people just use concatenate and
then put the axes in there because it's
much
has a lot more clarity and is more
more commonly used nowadays
the last section in numpy we're going to
cover uh is
underst is kind of data exploration
and they'll make a little bit more sense
in just a moment
sometimes they call them set operations
but let's say we have an array one two
three four five six three whatever it is
i think we generate a nice little array
here and what i want to go ahead and do
is find the unique
values in that array
uh so maybe i'm generating what they
call a one hot encoder
and so these values then all become i
need to know how long my bit array is
going to be
so each word how many how many each word
is represented by a number and then i
want to know just how many of those
words are in there if we're doing word
count very popular thing to do
and you can see here when we do unique
uh we have one two three four five six
those are our unique values
some of the things we can do with the
unique values is we can also instead of
doing just unique we can do uniques
our new unique values and counts of each
unique value
and this is very similar to what we just
did up here where we uh we're doing np
unique
but we're going to add a little bit more
into there
and it's just part of the arguments in
this and we want to do return
counts
equals
true so instead of just returning the
unique values
we want to know how many of those unique
values are in each one
and we'll go ahead and print
our uniques
and print
our counts
when we run that
you can see here we have our unique
value one two three four five six just
like we had before and then there's two
of the first of two ones two twos two
threes two fours one five two sixes and
so on and you can go through and
actually look at that if you want to
count them
but a quick way to find out your
distribution of different values
so you might want to know how often the
word the is used versus the word and if
each word is represented as a unique
number
and along the set variables we might
want to know
let me just put a note up here
we're going to start looking at
intersection
and we might want to also know
differentiation
and
neither
so when we're whoops neighbor
so what we're looking at now is we want
to know hey where do these two arrays
intersect and we have one two three four
five three four five six seven we might
wanna know what is common between the
two arrays
um and so when we do that we have uh np
intersect
and it's a 1d array one dimensional
array
and then we need to go ahead and put
one array two
and if we run this
we can see they intersect at three four
five that's what they have common
uh and because we're going to go ahead
and go through these and look at a
couple different options let's change
this from intersect 1d
and we'll do the same thing we'll go
ahead and print this
so we might want to know the
intersection
where they have commonalities
another
unique word is union of 1d
so instead of intersect
we want to know all the values that are
in both of them so here's our union of
1d when we run that you can see we have
one two three four five six seven so
it's all the different values in there
and the last one of the last words we
have two more to go uh is we want to
know what the set difference is
uh and so that's where the you'll see
that if you remember set we talked about
that being the what they call these
things
so the set difference
of a 1d array when we run that
you can see that one
is only in one array and two is only in
one array
and if we want to know uh what's in
array 1 but not in array 2 we might want
to know what is in array 1 but not 2 and
what's in 2 but not 1
and this would be the set x or
1d on here
so we have the four different options
here where we can do an intersection
what do they both have in common
we can do a union what are all the
unique values in both arrays
we can see the difference what's in
array one but not array two so set diff
one d
and then set x or what is not in one
but is in two and what is in not in two
but in one
so we dug a lot in numpy because we're
talking um there's a lot of different
little mathematical things going on in
numpy
a lot of this can also be done in pandas
although usually the heavy lifting is
left for numpy because that's what it's
designed for let's go ahead and open up
another python three
setup in here
and so we want to explore what happens
when you want to display this this is
where it starts getting
in my opinion a little fun because
you're actually playing with it and you
have something to show people
and we'll go ahead and rename this we're
going to call this pandas
and pie plot
so pandas pie plot
just so we can remember for next time
and we want to go ahead and import the
necessary libraries we're going to
import pandas as pd now remember this is
a data frame so we're talking rows and
columns and you'll see how
pandas work so nicely when you're
actually showing data to people
and then we're going to have numpy in
the background numpy works with pandas
so a lot of times you just import them
by default
seaborn sits on top of the matplot
library
so sometimes we use the seaborn because
it kind of extends it's one of the 100
packages that extends the matplot
library probably the most common used
because it has a lot of built-in
functionality
almost by default i usually just put
cborn in there in case i need it and of
course we have matplot library as pi
plot as plt
and note we have as pd as np as sns as
plt
those are pretty standard so when you're
doing your imports i would probably keep
those just so other people can read your
code and it makes sense to them that's
pretty much a standard nowadays
and then we have the strange line here
uh it says amber sign matplot library
inline
that is for jupiter notebook only so if
you're running this in a different
package it will have a pop-up when it
goes to display the matplot library you
can with the
most current version of jupiter usually
leave that out and it will still display
it right on the page as we go and we'll
see what that looks like
and then we're going to go ahead and
just do the seaborn the sns.set and
we're going to set the color codes
equals true
let them just keep the default one so we
don't have to think about it too much
and we of course have to run this
the reason we run this is because these
values are all set if we don't run this
and i access one of these
afterward
it will crash
the cool thing about jupiter notebooks
is if you forgot to import one of these
you forgot to install it because you do
have to install this under your anaconda
setup or whatever setup you're in you
can flip over to anaconda and run your
install for these
and then just come back and run it you
don't have to close anything out
and we'll go ahead and paste this one in
here real quick we have car equals pd
dot read underscore csv
and then we have the actual path
this path of course will vary depending
on what you are working with
so it's wherever you save the file at
and you can see here i have like
my onedrive documents simply learn
python data analytic using python slash
car csv it's quite a long file
when we open that up what we get is we
get a csv file and we have the make the
model the year the engine fuel type
engine horsepower
cylinders and so on
and this is just a comma separated file
so each row is like a row of data think
of it as a spreadsheet
and then each one is a column of data on
here and as you can see right here it
has the make model so it has columns for
a header on here
now your pandas just does an excellent
job of automatically pulling a lot of
this in so when you start seeing the
pandas on here
you realize that you are already like
halfway done with getting your data in i
just love pandas for that reason numpy
also has it you can load a csv directly
into numpy
but we're working with pandas and this
is where it really gets cool is i can
come down here
and i can print remember our print
statement we can actually get rid of it
and we're just going to do car head
because it's going to print that out
the head is going to print the top
values of that data file we just ran in
and so you can see right here it does a
nice printout it's all nice and inline
because we're in jupiter notebook i can
scroll back and forth and look at the
different data
and just like we expected we have our
column and it brought the header right
in
one thing to note is the index it
automatically created an index 0 1 2 3 4
and so on and we're just looking at the
head so we got 0 1 2 3 4.
you can change this you might want to
just look at the top two
we can run that there's our top two bmws
another thing we can do is instead of
head we can do tail
and look at the last three values that
are in that data file
and you can see right here it numbered
them all the way up to
11913 oh my goodness they put a lot of
data in this file i didn't even look to
see how big the file was
so you can really easily get through and
view the different data in here
when you're talking about big data
you almost never just print out car
in fact let's see what happens when we
do if we run this and we just run the
car
it's huge
in fact it's so big that the pandas
automatically truncates it and just does
head plus tell so you can see the two um
so we really don't want to look at the
whole thing i'm going to go back to
let's stick with the head
displaying our data there we go so
there's a head of our data gives us a
quick look to see what's actually in
there
i can zoom out if we want so you can
actually get a better view
although we'll keep it zoomed in so you
can see the code i'm working on
and then from the data standpoint we
course want to look at
data types uh what's going on with our
data what does it look like
now this you know you show your when
you're talking to your shareholders
they like to see these nice easy to read
charts they look like a spreadsheet so
it's a nice way of displaying pieces of
the chart
we talk about the data types now we're
getting into the data science side of it
what are we working with well we have
make model we have an integer 64 for the
year
uh engine fuel type is an object if we
go up here you can see that there most
of them are
like you know it's a set manual rear
wheel drive
so they might be very
limited number of types in there
uh and so forth and you'll it's either
gonna be a float64 an integer or an
object is the way it's going to read it
on here
and the next thing you're going to know
is like your columns
and since it loaded the columns
automatically
we have here the make the model the year
the engine
the size all the way up to the msrp
and
just out of something you'll see come up
a lot
is whenever you're in pandas and you
type in dot values
it converts it from a pandas list to a
numpy array
and that's true of any of these so then
you end up in an empty array so you'll
see a little switch in there in the way
that the data is actually stored and
that's true of any of these
uh in this case we want car dot columns
you have a total list of your car
columns
and like any good data
scientist we want to start looking at
analytical summary of the data set
what's going on with our data so we can
start trying to
piecemeal it together so we can do car
describe
and then we'll do is we'll do include
equals
all
so a nice panda command is to describe
your data
if you're working with r this should
start looking familiar
and we come down here and you can see
count there's a
make the model the year
how many of each one
how many unique values of each one
the top value of each one what's most
common the frequency the mean
um clearly on some of these it's an
object so it really can't tell you what
the
average is
you know it'd just be the top ones the
average i guess
the year what's the average year on
there
all this stuff comes down here your
standard deviation your minimum value
your maximum value
uh what's in the lower quarter
50 percent mark where's that line at and
what's in the upper 75 percent the top
25 going into the max
now this next part is just cool uh this
is what we always wanted computers to be
back like in the 90s instead of 5 000
lines of code to do this maybe not 5
000.
all right i built my own plot
library back in 95 and the amount of
code for doing a simple plot
was um
i don't know probably about 100 lines of
code
this is being done in one line of code
we have our car which is our pandas we
generated that it's our data frame and
we have dot hist for histogram that is
the power of seaborn now it's still
going to generate a numpy graph but
seaborn sits on top and then we can do
the figure size this is just um
so it fits nicely on the paper on here
and we do something simple like this and
you can see here where it comes up and
does a map plot library and does
subplots and everything
but we're looking at a histogram of all
the different pieces in our database
and we have our engine cylinders um
that's always a good one because you can
see like they have some that are they
had a null on there so they came out as
zero
maybe a couple maybe one of them had a
two cylinder engine away back when
four is a common uh six a little less
common and then you see the eight
cylinder
uh 12 cylinder engines well it's got to
be a speedster or something
but you can see right here just breaks
it down so now you have
how many cars
with how many whatever it is cylinders
horsepower
and so on and it does a nice job
displaying it
you can see if you're working with your
um
you're going into your demo it's really
nice just to be able to type that in and
boom there it is it can see it all the
way across
and we might want to zero in and use
like a box plot and this time we'll go
ahead and call the
seaborn sns box plot and we're going to
go ahead and do
vehicle size in versus
engine horsepower xy plot and the data
comes from the car so if we run this we
end up with a nice box plot
you see our mid-size compact and large
you can see the variation there's our
outlier showing up there on the compact
that must be a high-end sports car
a large car might have a couple engines
and again we have all these outliers and
then your deviation on them
very powerful and quick way to zero in
on one small piece of data and display
it for people who need to have it
reduced to something they can see and
look at and understand and that's our
seabourn box plot or sns.box plot
and then if we're going to back out and
we want a quick look at
what they call pair plotting
we can run that and you can see with the
seaborn it just does all the work for
you
it takes just a moment for it to pull
the data in and compile it
and once it does it creates a nice grid
and this grid if you look at this one
space here which is you might not be
able to see the small number it says
engine horsepower this is engine
horsepower
to the year it was built
and it's just flipped so everything to
the right of the middle diagonal is just
the rotation of what's on the left and
as you expect
the engine horsepower
gets bigger and bigger and bigger as
time goes on so the the year it was
built the further up in the year the
more likely you are to have a heavy
horsepower engine
and you can quickly look at trends
with our pair plot coming up and look
how fast that was that was it took a
couple moment to process
but right away i get a nice view of all
these different information which i can
look at visually and and kind of see how
things group and look
now if i was doing a meeting i probably
wouldn't show all the data
one of the things i've learned over the
years is
people myself included love to show all
our work you know we're taught in school
show all your work prove what you know
the ceo doesn't want to see a huge
grid of of graphs i guarantee it
so we want to do is we want to go ahead
and drop
the stuff that might not be interested
in and we're going to i'm not really a
car person
a guy in the back is obviously
so you have your engine fuel type we're
going to drop that we're going to drop
market category vehicle style popularity
number of doors vehicle size
um and we have the axis in here if you
remember from numpy we have to include
that axis to make it clear what we're
working on that's also true with pandas
and then we'll look at just that what it
looks like from the head
and you can see that we dropped out
those categories and now we have the
make model year and so forth
and we took out the engine fuel type
market category etc
and this should look familiar to you now
when you start working with pandas i
just love pandas for this reason look
how easy it is it just displays it as a
nice
spreadsheet for you you can just look at
it and view it very easily
it's also the same kind of view you're
going to get if you're working in spark
or pi spark which is python for spark
across big data this is the kind of
thing that they they come up with this
is why pandas is so powerful
and we may look at this and decide we
don't like these columns
and so you can go in here and we can
actually rename the columns
simple command car equals car rename
columns equals engine horsepower equals
horsepower
this is just your standard python
dictionary
so it just maps them out and you know
instead of having like a lengthy effect
here we had
engine horsepower we just want
horsepower we don't need to know what's
the engine horsepower
engine cylinders we don't need to know
that it's for the engine because there's
only one thing we're describing if we're
talking about cars and that cylinders
and we'll go ahead and just run this and
again here's our car head and you can
see how that changed we have model year
in horsepower versus model year engine
horsepower engine cylinders and just
cylinders
again we want to keep reducing this so
it's more and more readable the more
readable you get it the better um and of
course we can also adjust the size a
little bit
so that when it prints out instead of
splitting it on two lines we get like a
single line we can do that also that's
just your control mouse up or plus sign
you use in chrome that's a chrome
command
and if you remember from numpy we had
shape well pandas works the same way
we can look at the shape of the data so
we now have
nine hundred fourteen rows and ten
columns uh so you see some similarities
because pandas is built on numpy
and
questions that come up just like you did
in numpy we might wanna know duplicate
rows and so we can do car and look at
this switch here
we're doing a selection this is a panda
selection with the brackets
but we want to select it based on car
dot duplicated so how many duplicates on
there
so we're starting to look a little bit
different as far as how we access some
of the data on here this can be a
logical statement and we get the number
of duplicate rows we have 989 rows by 10
columns again
and this is one of those troubleshooting
things that we end up doing a lot more
than we really feel like we should
uh we might go ahead and do like a car
count uh just to see how many rows we're
dealing with
and then right after that we might want
to go ahead and say hey
let's drop duplicates so remember we did
all the duplicates on there so car
equals car dot drop duplicates and then
we can print the head again we'll just
do car head here and you can see the
data on there
looks the same as before
and just note that we did car equals car
draw duplicates
there are commands in here where you can
do where it changes the actual value and
it works on some of them and not on
others depending on what you're doing
but by default it always returns a copy
so when we do this we're reassigning it
to car
and you can see it's the same header but
we want to go ahead and do count and see
how the count changes let's go ahead and
run this and you can see here instead of
11 914 we have 10 925
so we've removed
about 100 cars
that were duplicated just slightly under
100 there
and then as we're prepping our data we
might want to know um
car is null
so it's going to count the values of
null and then we want to sum that up
and when we do that
we do the car is no function sum uh we
end up with
hp the horsepower is 69 have no values
and 30 have cylinders have no values
now if you don't put the sum at the end
it's just going to return
a mask with the true false of is it null
or is it not
by
zero and one so you're summing up the
ones underneath each column
and this of course then you have to
decide what you're going to do with the
null values there's a lot of different
options it might be that you need to put
in the average or means
maybe you want to put in the median
value
there's a lot of different ways to fill
it
usually when you first start out with
the data a lot of them you just drop
your null values and you can see here
car dot drop in a
which is equal to all and then we're
going to go ahead and count it and you
can see that we've dropped almost
another 100 values so from 10 9 25
to 10 8 27
maybe 75 or so values
so we clean that this is really a big
part of cleaning data you need to know
how to get rid of your null values or at
least count them and what to do with
them
and of course if we go back to
counting our null values we should now
have
no no values
there we go and you'll see there's zero
null values
i don't know how many times i've been
running a model that doesn't take no
values and it crashes and i just sit
there and look at it trying to get why
did that crash it should have worked
it's because i forgot to remove the null
values
so we've been jumping around a lot we're
going to go back to
finding outliers and let's go ahead and
bring that back into our seabourn and if
you remember we did a box plot earlier
this time we're going to do a box plot
just on the price
and you can see here
our price value
and we have the deviation with the two
thinner bars on each side of the main
value
and then as we get up here we have all
these outliers in fact we have one way
out here that's um
probably a really expensive high-end car
is what we're looking at
if you were doing um fraud analysis you
would be jumping on all over these
outliers why are these deviation from
the standard what are these people doing
again this is probably like i said a
really high-end expensive car out here
that's what we're looking at
and we can also look at the
box plot for the horsepower
and we'll put that in down here
and run that
and you can see again here's our
horsepower and it just jumps and there's
these really odd huge muscle cars out
here that are outliers
and we're going to jump into making this
a little bit more
as you start displaying your data or
your information to your shareholders
we're going to look at plotting a
histogram for the number of cars per
brand
and the first thing we want to go ahead
and do
is we have with our car and go back over
here here we go
we have our make value counts largest
plot
and we're going to do a kind equals bar
figure size 10-5
and
right off the bat we jump up here we see
chevrolet it's going against what was it
it's uh figure resolution the value
counts and we want the largest value so
here's our value counts and compared to
what the different cars are chevrolet
puts out a lot of different kinds of
cars i didn't realize that they made
that many cars
or different types
and then for readability let's go ahead
and add a title number of cars by make
number of cars and make if you looked at
this the first time you would have been
like well what the heck am i looking at
well we're looking at the number of cars
by make and then you can see here now
we're talking about the type of cars
and the different ones are put out lotus
i guess only had a few different kinds
of cars over there very high-end cars
and then as doing data analytics and as
a data scientist one of the things i am
most interested in is the relationship
between the variables
so this is always a place to start we
want to know what's going on with our
variables and how they connect with each
other
so the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to go ahead and set a figure
size because we want to make sure
it fits our graph
we'll just go ahead and set this one
plot figure set to figure size 2010.
if you never use the matplot library
which is sitting behind seaborne
whatever is in the plt
this is what's loaded it's like a canvas
you're painting on so the second you
load that
pi plot as plt
anything you do to that is affecting
everything on it
and then we want to go ahead uh since
we're using seaborn
we'll go ahead and create a variable c
for
uh relationships or correspondence
and car dot co r r that's a correlation
in seabourn on top of pandas again
one line and you get the whole
correlation on there
and because we're working with seaborn
let's put it into a nice heat map
if you're not familiar with heat maps
that means we're just using color as
part of our
setup so we have a nice visual
and we can see here that the seaborne
connected to the pandas prints out a
nice chart
we'll talk a little bit about the color
here in a second it prints out a nice
chart this is a chart i look at as a
data scientist these are the numbers i
want to look at
and we'll just highlight one of them um
here's cylinders
versus horsepower the closer to one the
higher the correlation so 0.788 pretty
high correlation between the number of
cylinders and how heavy the horsepower
is
i'm betting if you looked at the year
versus horsepower
we just look at that one here's year and
horsepower
0.314 not as so much but if you combine
them you don't actually add them but if
you combine them you'll start to see an
increase in horsepower per year and
cylinders you could probably get a
correlation there
and just like .78 is a positive
correlation
you might notice if we look at cylinders
and or let's look at horsepower and
mileage
uh so if we go here to horsepower to
mileage you get a nice
negative we'll do cylinders that's a
bigger number with cylinders to the
miles per gallon it's a minus 0.6 so
it's a negative correlation the closer
to minus 1 the more the negative
correlation is
and then the chart you would actually
show people is a nice heat map this is
all our colors and it's just those
numbers put into a heat map the darker
the color the higher the correlation you
can see straight down the middle
obviously the year correlates directly
with the year horsepower with horsepower
and so on that's why it's a one the
closer to the one the higher the
correlation between the two pieces of
data
now this is a good introduction pandas
goes way beyond this most the
functionality in numpy since panda sits
on it is also in pandas and then it even
has additional features in it and we use
seaborne pretty extensively sitting on
top over our pie plot so keep in mind
that our pie plot has a ton of other
features in it that we didn't even touch
on in here
we couldn't even if you had a soul
course in it uh there's just so many
things hidden in there depending on what
your domain you're working on
but you can see here here's our seabourn
and here's our matplot library that's
all our graphics that we did and then
the seaborn works really nicely with the
pandas
we really like that
so that wraps up our demo part for today
let's understand a case study from
walmart and how it uses data analytics
to grow its business and serve its
customers better
walmart is an american multinational
retail company
that has over 11 500 stores in 27
countries worldwide and it has
e-commerce websites in 10 different
countries
it has more than 5900 retail units
operating outside the united states with
55 banners in 26 countries with more
than 7 lakh associates serving more than
100 million customers every week
it has over 2.2 million employees around
the world and 1.5 million employees in
the united states alone
walmart's e-commerce branch alone
employs more than 3 000 technologies
from silicon valley to india england and
south america
more than 240 million customers shop at
walmart each week online and at its
banner stores
walmart.com sees up to 100 million
unique visitors a month according to
comscore and is growing every year
walmart collects over 2.5 petabytes of
data from 1 million customers every hour
that's really huge
now to make sense of all this
information walmart has created data
cafe a state of the art analytics hub
located within its bantonville arkansas
headquarters
here over 200 streams of internal and
external data including 40 petabytes of
recent transactional data can be modeled
manipulated and visualized teams from
any part of the business are invited to
bring their problems to the analytics
experts and then see a solution appear
before the rise on the nerve center's
touchscreen smart boards
walmart also constantly analyzes over
100 million keywords to know what people
near each store are saying on social
media to understand the customer
behavior on what they like and dislike
walmart uses modern tools and
technologies to derive business insights
and improve customer satisfaction some
of these tools include python sas nosql
databases such as cassandra and hadoop
now using all these technologies and
data analysis techniques walmart can
better manage its supply chain optimize
product assortment personalize the
shopping experience give relevant
product recommendations and finally
optimize and analyze transportation
lanes and routes for its fleet of trucks
with that
let's jump into our use case demo where
we will predict the sales based on
advertising expenditure using the linear
regression model in r
the advertising expenditure has been
made via different mediums such as radio
television and newspaper
we will use the r programming software
to implement the demo
so why are
well r is a free and open source
software that can be downloaded from the
arc rand website it is easy to learn and
use
our language is built specifically for
performing statistical analysis data
manipulation and data mining using
packages such as player deep player
tidier and lubridate
r supports data visualization with the
help of packages such as ggplot google
waste r color brewer leaflet and gg map
and finally the r software can be used
in a wide range of analytical modeling
including classical statistical tests
linear and non-linear modeling data
clustering time series analysis and more
now let's have a look at our data that
we will be using for this demo
here is our advertising csv data set
which has four columns
you can see this
tv ads expenditure
the next column is for radio ads then we
have the newspaper ads and the last
column is our target column that is the
sales
so
the data set has
in total 200 rows
now
to understand the data let me give an
example
so consider the second row
so suppose you spend around 230 dollars
on tv ads
then 37.8 dollars on radio ads
and 69.2 dollars newspaper ads you can
expect to sell nearly 22 units of a
particular product
similarly
if you are spending 44.5 dollars in tv
advertising
39.3 dollars in radio ads
and 45 dollars in newspaper ads you can
sell around
10 units of certain item
we will analyze this data using linear
regression so linear regression is a
supervised learning algorithm which
means the data has labeled columns and
is used to predict numeric continuous
variables
so our sales column here is the target
column and it has continuous numeric
variables
now let me go to the r studio and start
with the demo
so first
i'll create a new file then i'll select
our script
the next step is to install all the
necessary packages that we need for this
demo
if you already have the packages
installed in your r studio you need not
do it again you can just call these
packages using the library function and
pass the package names
so first
i will install the dplyer package which
is used for data manipulation
i'll be using install.packages function
and i'll give the package name
so i'll type
install dot packages if you hit tab it
will auto complete
then under
quotations
i'll write dplyer
i'm not going to run this because i
already have it installed in my r studio
the next step i'll write i'll call this
package using library function i'll give
the package name deployer
i'll run this
then i'll install the broom package it
takes the messy output of built-in
functions in r such as linear model or
lm then t test and turns them into a
tidy data frame
so i'll copy the above code
i'll just paste it again
i'll change it to
broom
here also i'll change it to broom
i'll run this
ok
then i'll be installing the ca tools
package
which will help us build our linear
regression model
paste the same code
and i'll take ca tools
and i'll call that using the library
function
run this
now sometimes people face issues with
installing this particular package if
you also face this problem do visit the
rstudio community page now let me show
it to you
so
this is the r studio community page
and here they have the solution you can
just go through this
two pages
all right
after this i will install the ggplot2
package which is a very popular package
in r for data visualization
i'm not running installed packages
because i have already installed all
these packages before
if you have not so you have to run
install.packages first and then call the
library function
with that
let's now load the data set
for this i will use the read.csv
function and provide the path location
where my data is located
followed by the dataset name and the
extension
i'll assign the loaded dataset to a
variable
let me now go ahead and show you where
my data set is located
so here is my advertising csv data set
and this is the location i'll copy this
location
i'll move back to rstudio
and
let me comment this line
load the data set
so i'll
take a variable name
ads
and then using
read.csv function
i'll pass the path location where the
dataset is present
now one thing to
note is we have to change all the
backslash to forward slash otherwise r
won't accept it
and finally
i'll give the
data set
name which is
advertising
dot csv
let me run it
okay we have successfully loaded our
data set
now let us look at how our data set
looks like using the head function
so i'll give a comment display
the head
of the data set
i'll be using the head function and i'll
pass
ads
run it
so
you can see
the head function has displayed the
first six rows
from the advertising data set
let me now check the dimensions of the
data set so i'll use the dim function
it will give you the total rows and
columns present in the data set
give a comment
check
the
dimensions
i'll use the dim function and i'll pass
in the ads variable
you can see
it has given the number of rows which is
200 and the total columns which is 4.
now if you want to get a summary of the
data set you can use the summary
function
so i'll directly type in summary
and i'll give ads
let me expand this
so actually summary function gives you
information about a few statistics for
each of the columns
so you can see
the minimum value for each column the
maximum value for each column
the mean the median
first quartile and the third quartile
values
the first quartile or lower quartile is
the value that cuts off the first 25
percent of the data when it is sorted in
ascending order
the second quartile is the median which
has the value that cuts off the first 50
percent
and the third quartile
or the upper quartile is the value that
cuts off the first 75 percent of data
moving ahead
let's do some data visualization now to
visualize our data
since our data has only numeric values
using scatter plots would be the best
option
so we will visualize our sales against
each of the independent variables for
that i will use the plot function and
give sales in my x axis and the
independent variable names in the y axis
let me now do that
so i will give a comment
data
visualization
first
i'll use the plot function
and then
in x-axis using the
dollar symbol
i'll give sales
then in the y-axis
i'll give
my independent variable
you can see r is automatically
giving you the suggestions i'll select
tv
then
i'll take type
is equal to
under quotes i'll give p which stands
for points
and i'll take the color as
red
so you can see under plots we have
our scatter plot
if i zoom in
you can see
the red dots are pretty much aligned in
one direction which means
if you are increasing the expenditure on
tv ads the units sold are also
increasing equally
so the more you spend on tv ads the more
sales you can expect
i'll close it
now let's look at how sales vary based
on radio advertising expenditure
i'll copy this
paste it
and under y-axis i'll change it to
radio
and i'll take the color now as
let's say blue color
i'll run it
now if out
to zoom in
now
if you look at the blue dots it is not
that linear compared to our previous
graph
you can see there are a few data points
like this
that show the sales were not good even
after spending decent money on radio ads
but still you can expect a decent amount
of sales if you are willing to spend on
radio advertising
close it
let's now look at how sales will vary
based on the newspaper advertising
expenditure
i'll change the radio to
newspaper column
and this time i'll take color as
green
i'll run it
zoom in
you can see
the plots are very haphazardly present
the data is completely non-linear and
there seems to be a low correlation
between the sales and newspaper
advertising expenditure
now if you want to look at these plots
at a time you can use the pairs function
so i'll type peers and then
pass in my variable name which is ads
i'll run it
let me zoom in
so this is our plot
and you can see
this has all the
visualizations so you can see the tv
sales
now you can see
the sales that were made
with radio expenditure and with the
newspaper expenditure as well
i'll close it
moving ahead
let's check the correlation between the
variables and see what inside we can get
we will use the core function or cor
function and build a correlation matrix
first
let me go ahead and install the core
plot package
so i'll give a comment
correlation analysis
for this i will have to install
the core plot package
i've already got it installed
then i'll call this function using
library
i'll run
it
you can see core plot the version has
been uploaded
now
i'll tell you how you can grab only the
numeric columns
now data only has numeric columns but
still let me tell you how you can do it
since correlations are based on numeric
columns only
this can be done using the s apply
function
so for that we have already installed
the d player library
i'll give a
variable name as
num dot calls
which is
numeric columns
then i'll
pass in the supply function
i'll give
the ads variable and i'll check if the
variable is numeric or not so i'll use
is dot numeric
let me run it
and now
let's display what's there in num.calls
you can see
it says tb it's true which means db has
numeric values even radio has numeric
values
similarly for newspaper and sales also
then
i'll use the correlation function which
is cor to display the correlations
between the variables
so i'll give my variable name as
cor dot data
and then
i'll take the core function
pass in the ads variable
and i'll only filter out
the
numeric columns
so comma numeric columns means we need
all the rows and the selected columns
let me run it
and now to display let me call cor dot
data again
so this is our correlation output
as you can see the correlation values
are all above zero which means there is
a positive correlation between the
variables and the change in one of the
independent variables will have a
positive impact on the sales numbers
tv ads
have the maximum correlation with sales
and the value is around 0.78
then there is radio advertising which
has correlation of about 0.57
with sales and newspaper ads have the
lowest correlation compared to the other
two which is at 0.22
now
you can also build a correlation matrix
using the correlation plot method
this will give you a visual
representation of the correlation
between the variables
so let's see how we can do that
i'll type
core plot
and i'll give
code.data
and i'll pass a method
as color
by zoom in
you can see
this is our correlation matrix
on the right
you can see the scale so minus 1
is for negative correlation
then this light red
0 which is almost
white color then there is light blue and
finally dark blue for the maximum
positive correlation
the diagonals
are dark blue which represents the same
variables as in rows and in columns so
it's dark blue
tv ads
and radio ads have the next highest
correlation
but newspaper ads have the lowest
correlation with sales
with that
let's jump into the most important part
of this analysis
which is building our regression model
first we will look at a simple linear
regression model where we will take one
input variable that is tv ads
i'll be using the lm function or the
linear model function
to build the model
so i'll give a comment simple
linear
regression
i'll take a variable name as model
underscore
simple
and then using lm function
i'll give my target variable which is
sales and
using tild
i'll give my independent variable which
is tb
and data
ads
i'll run it
now that we have built our linear
regression model let's check the summary
take summary function and i'll pass in
model underscore simple
let me run it
now if i expand this
you can see
our intercept estimate is
around 7.03
so when the tv advertising budget is
zero
we can expect sales to be around
or 7030
also remember we are operating in units
of thousand
and for every
thousand dollar increase in the tv
advertising budget we can expect the
average increase in sales to be around
47 units
now the same summary can be checked
using the tidy function
present in the broom package
so if i call
tidy and i'll give the
model name which is model underscore
simple
i'll run it
so there you go this gives us a tidy
representation of the summary figures
now
let's build a regression model with more
than one input variable
so
we'll build a multiple linear regression
model
i'll take my variable name as model
underscore multiple this time
and
i'll use the same lm function
i'll pass in the sales
and using
till
i'll take all the column names
stevie then i'll use an addition
operator
and i'll take in newspaper
followed by
the radio column
and then i'll take my data as ads
let's run it
i'll follow the same drill let me now
call the summary function over this
newly created model
so i'll write summary
and i'll select
my model name as model underscore
multiple
let me run it
so the interpretation of our
coefficients is the same as in simple
linear regression model
first we see that our coefficients for
tv and radio advertising budget are
statistically significant
since
our p value is less than 0.05
while the coefficient of newspaper is
not which is around 0.86
thus changes in the newspaper budget
does not appear to have any relationship
with changes in sales
however for tv ads our coefficients
suggest that for every thousand dollar
increase in tv advertising budget
holding any other predictors constant we
can expect an increase in sales of
45 units
on average
similarly the radio coefficient suggests
that for every thousand dollar increase
in radio advertising holding all the
other predictors constant
we can expect an increase of 188 sales
units on an average
now you can also call the tidy function
over this multiple linear regression
model
so let me do that
i'll call tidy and i'll pass in
model underscore multiple
you can see it has given the output
now you can also find the coefficients
of the model using another method it's
called the coefficient matrix
here is how you can do that so
take a variable name
and
i'll use the summary function
i'll pass in model underscore multiple
and
using the dollar symbol i'll take the
parameter as coefficient
let me call c coefficient now
so these are the coefficients of
different variables
let me now show you another example of
how you can train a linear regression
model using the ca tools library
first i'll take a seed value a random
seed value of say
next i will split the data into training
and testing sets
i'll take 70 for training the data and
30 for testing the data
so i'll use a variable sample
then
i'll call sample.split
take ads and then
then i'll use another parameter called
split ratio
and i'll take the split ratio as 0.7
which is 70 percent
run it
and then
i'll
use another variable called train
and
take the subset of the sample
pass in my ads variable
and i'll select sample is equal to equal
to
true
similarly
i'll take another variable called test
i'll
use my subset function and
given the same parameters
but this time i'll take sample
is equal to equal to
false
which means
the test sample data set won't have any
values that are present in trained data
set
i'll run it
now
we will use the same lm function to
create our model
so i'll take model
as my variable
and assign it to
lm function
so i'll assign the linear model to
the model variable i'll take sales as my
target column
use the tilde followed by a dot which
means i am taking all the variables
in terms of the independent variables
and then
i'll select my trained data set
with that let's check the summary as
well
so this is the summary of our
newly created model
now you can also check the residual
collector from the trained model using
the residuals function
let me go ahead and assign a variable
called res for residual and i'll use the
residuals function
pass in my model
then
i'll convert the residuals into a data
frame
so
i'll use the as dot data frame
function and pass in res
you can check the residuals
so these are the residual values
now it's time to make our predictions
using the test data set i'll use the
predict function for this
let me take another variable called
sales dot predictions
and
i'll use the predict function
pass in my model followed by the test
data set now
i'll run it
then let me call sales.prediction to
display the values
as you can see
these are my predicted sales values
now let me combine this predictive sales
values to our original sales for the
test data
for that i'll use the cbind function and
pass the column names
i'll take another variable called
results
and use the c bind function
i'll take sales.predictions
and i'll consider
the sales column from the test data
let me check the values now
so you have the predicted sales values
and the original values of sales
but you can see the columns don't have
any name assigned to them
so let me go ahead and assign the column
names using the call names function and
convert it into a data frame to make it
look better
so i'll use the call names
function and
and pass in my results variable
then
i'll take a vector and
give the column names as spread for
predicted values and let's say real for
the original values
let me run it
now i'll convert this into a
data frame so i'll use as dot data dot
frame
and give my results variable
now if i
display results
you can see
go on top
you can see the columns have been
assigned successfully so on the left you
have the predicted values and on the
right you have the real values
so we have successfully built our linear
regression model and predicted the sales
values using linear regression in r
you can also go ahead and find the
accuracy of this model
to know how good your model is we won't
be covering that as part of this
tutorial i'll leave it for you and
encourage you to do some research on how
you can find the accuracy of a linear
regression model
you will come across terms such as mean
squared error root mean squared error
and r squared value
if you are able to find the accuracy
please post the results in the comment
section or if you face any issues with
it please post your queries we'll be
happy to help you
let us quickly hop on to our studio and
start performing the hands-on exercise
for data analysis
for this exercise we will use a data set
named as demographics which is in a dot
csv file type
firstly let us load the data set to
rstudio and we will locate this in a
variable named as demo
we also refer to this as a data frame
and now you will notice that a variable
is created in an environment section
which is in the bottom right hand side
of the rstudio window
and this particular variable comprises
of 510 observations or records with
eight variables
let us simply
expand this particular data frame and
have a quick check on the data structure
and understand the data types
this particular data frame includes
variables such as age
marital
income
the unit of income is dollar per day
education levels
the car price car category with several
levels
gender
and retired status
let us view the top six records of this
particular data set
for this let's simply type head of demo
and the result is now visible in the
console section if you're interested to
view all the records then simply type
view of demo
and this new window will show you every
single record that is being loaded to
our studio
you may also simply apply the filters
and the filter section here on
individual categorical variables
now that we have loaded the data set and
also viewed individual records let us
focus on creating subsets of records
by applying filters on individual
variables or multiple variables
so firstly let us apply filter on gender
we will only retrieve the records where
gender is equal to female
and we will locate these records in a
variable named as demo 2.
as you notice now in the environment
section the second variable is also
created that is demo and this now is
comprising of 250 observation which
means the records are filtered down to
only gender female
next let us see how to apply a filter on
income variable let us only retrieve the
records where income is greater than
100.
let's view the result
as we say here all the records include
income greater than 100.
now let us modify this query
and
we will ensure that the retrieved
records includes
income greater than 100
and also specific variables are returned
let's say we only want to have
the first variable third variable and
the seventh variable returned as the
result
let's have a quick check
so we only have the first third and the
seventh variable returned
how about we only exclude
the variable
six to eight
for this we include a prefix of minus
sign
and now let us see what is the result
we have the variables from first to the
fifth variable however we don't have six
seventh and eighth variable
i hope it's clear so far
yes
all right now let us see how can we
apply condition by including both the
variables that is gender and income and
then we will filter the record and
create a subset of data
now let's view the result
income is greater than 100
and the gender is only female
this is one way of creating subsets
however now let us see how to use the
subset command and create the subset
let's create a subset of records
by applying filter on marital status
and age
we'll only retrieve records where
marital status is equal to married
and age is greater than 35.
let's now view the result
so here we have the age greater than 35
and marathon status is married
let's use the same code
and this time we will retrieve selected
variables let's say variables ranging
from 1 to 3.
let's have a quick check so there are
three variables
age is greater than 35 and marathon
status is married
now let us see how to structure the data
by sorting the data frame in ascending
and in descending order
we will apply this order function on the
variable income
firstly let us see how to order income
variable in ascending order
let's do a quick check
and here we have income in ascending
order
now let's see
how to
modify the same code
and view the records
with income in descending order
so we have now the income in descending
order
how about include two variables and sort
the variables accordingly
firstly we will sort the records
by ordering income and age in ascending
order
let's quickly view the result we have
income in ascending and age as well in
ascending
let's now modify this code
this time
we will
order
income in descending
and age in ascending
let us view the result
so the income is in descending and age
is in ascending order
so hope this is clear on how to solve
the data frame by ascending and
descending order per variable or by
using multiple variables with this we
will focus on learning statistical
analysis
how to perform statistical analysis on
individual variable or multiple variable
let's start by understanding the data
distribution of variable income
so that we identify what is the minimum
value of income what is the maximum what
is the range what is median what is the
mean and we will also focus on the
quantile distribution
which is also analyzed in a box plot
what is the minimum
value
in the variable
income
it's 9
and what is the maximum
so we have the maximum value
now let us see what's the range
so the range shows you the result with
minimum and the maximum value
how about
the difference of maximum
and the minimum now let us focus on
other summaries of data distribution for
this variable income
let's identify what is the mean value of
income
the mean is 78.
let's also understand what is the
standard deviation
right so the standard deviation is one
one two dollar
let us see
what is the variance the variance should
be larger
than
the standard deviation
now let's say what is the
median absolute deviation
as you notice here
the median absolute deviation value is
lower than standard deviation
why do we make this comparison
from this it is evident
that median absolute deviation is robust
to outliers and standard deviation is
sensitive to outliers and also to the
change in the mean value
now let us understand the quantile
distribution this is the same analysis
that is visualized in a box plot
ranging from zero percent to hundred
percent identifying the individual data
points
and we can also refer and compare this
to the min the max and the median values
let us quickly see what is the median
value
of income
as you notice here the median is 45
as well the 50th percent of quantile is
45 which means zero percent is minimum
and hundred percent is the maximum value
now if your question is what is 25
percent and 75 percent
this is again used for identifying the
range of interquartile
the interquartile range is nothing but
the difference of 75 percent minus the
25 percent
let's quickly see what is the iqr
of income
the iqrf income is 58.
let us do a quick check
75 percent of quantile is 86 and in 5
percent of quantile is 28
and the value is 58 which is equal to
the iqr result
now that we have focused on the
statistical analysis of the individual
variables data distribution let us focus
on the data visualization
in this we will have a pictorial
representation of analysis to identify
the outliers to see what is the minimum
and where do we see the data densely
populated and how is it scattered etc
we will begin with creating a histogram
now histogram can be used for univariate
analysis
which means in the scenario we will
consider
income variable and we will see how the
count of income ranges gets distributed
in a histogram
for this we will have to
install a package called as ggplot2
and also call this library ggplot
let us install the package
now let us call the library
all right
and we are ready now to begin with
visualization
for this we will use the geometric
object histogram
on the data demo data frame
let me expand this window so that the
code is visible
and also use an aesthetic mapping
for variable income
this will be helpful for filling colors
or filtrations etc
and only include 30 bins
with individual bin size width
of 100 which means there will be 100
incomes in individual bins
let's quickly look at the distribution
of this histogram
as you notice there are couple of
outliers
the counts of these income range are
very limited
however we see the densely populated
income ranges
with higher counts
between 0 to 200
dollars per day
this is also a way to identify and
segment the customers
based on their income ranges
now let us see how to change the color
of this histogram and also the border of
the histogram
for this we will include some additional
options
such as fill
filled with blue color
and the border color
is
black now as you notice here the
executed code provides us the histogram
with blue color bars and black color
border lines
now we will focus on creating a facet
grid
face and grid is also an aesthetic
mapping object
we will see how to enable the multiple
histograms across the marital status and
the genders
so that we identify how the income is
distributed for individual marital
status as well the genders
let's zoom this view and have a look at
it
as you notice here there are some
interesting outliers here in the data
distribution
female unmarried drawing higher income
and male
unmarried and married also drawing
higher income as compared to the females
whereas if you notice that the female
unmarried is drawing much higher income
than the male
this may also be very much related to
the age
now let us see how to create a stacked
histogram when i say a stacked histogram
i mean instead of feeling the color we
will fill the gender
so that there is a stack within the
histogram
so as you notice here i have made couple
of changes
i have included fill equal to gender
within the aesthetic mapping now let us
look at this histogram as you see here
the gender is filled in the histogram
hence we have stacked distribution of
female and the male
now let us focus on creating a bar chart
with education versus income where we
can identify the education levels and
the income ranges for these education
levels
as you notice here we are going to
create a visualization where we have the
aggregation in form of mean
and the geometric object used here is
bar plot now let's zoom this view and
understand which education level
have higher average income
so as we see here the blue color bar is
the post undergraduate degree
which means this education level
draws
higher average income as compared to
other
education levels
now let's create a histogram
where we will see car price and the
number of cars for individual category
let's look at this visualization
this visualization provides some
interesting insight just by looking at
the distribution of the car prices and
the counts of the cars
at
the car category economy and even the
luxury luxury car category or car price
is pretty much distributed whereas
economy car category is tensed which
means that we could also look back into
the income and age variables and try to
figure out further more insights and
then a segment the customers for further
targeting of these customers
now what happens if we simply change
this bin width to 30.
as you observe here
changing the bin width or increasing the
bin width will also reduce the number of
bins
now we only have four bins here
and the car category is filled
that is what we have enabled within the
aesthetic mapping
and we see some
more interesting insight
as you look at the standard and the
luxury car category
the car prices are pretty much
overlapping
for the car category luxury and standard
this could be the starting car price of
the luxury brands
now let us create
a clustered bar chart
let's look at this visualization
in this visualization
as you observe though we have enabled
fill equal to gender in the aesthetic
mapping we do not have the view in
stacked form but we have the bars one
besides the other
it is also because we have enabled a
position called as position equal to
dodge
in the code
now what is the inside that we can draw
from this visualization
as you see
postgraduate degree with female gender
is drawing
higher average income as compared to any
other education level
now let us see how to create a box plot
for variable income across the genders
so the box plot can be enabled if there
is a bivariate analysis to be performed
on a continuous variable and a
categorical variable
or multiple categorical variables with a
continuous variable
now let's look at this visualization
what does this say
we have data distribution of income
for individual genders that is for
female and the male
and we also notice outliers here
anything above this whisker is
considered to be outliers
it might make more sense if we also
include some coloring for these outliers
maybe also enable shape
now we have colored the outliers
and it's colored orange
let's see if we can also enable the
shapes
and now we have here the outlier color
as well the shape enabled
now let us see how to enable a violin
plot
what is the utility of violin plot with
the box plot we understand the analysis
and the distribution of the data points
is to identify the outliers to know what
is the minimum value what is the max
what is the median and what are the
outliers
but what is the purpose of a violin plot
let us have a quick check
as you observe there is some
concentration of data points in the
bottom of every car category
however the concentration is higher for
standard car category as compared to
economy and the luxury
now this is an interesting insight that
you wouldn't have come across in box
plot the box plot is a very good
representation for identifying outliers
however violent plot will help you focus
on the nuances which is not captured by
the box plot
we can also simply combine the box plot
and the violin plot together
simply include this jaw
object
let's zoom this
now you have a representation of box
plot and the violin plot both combined
in a single visualization
interestingly you notice the outliers as
well the concentration in the bottom of
this violin plot so this could be some
interesting insights that you draw and
focus on these data points and
understand what exactly is happening
there
now let's focus on the density plot that
is density estimate of the histograms
rather than just viewing the frequencies
now we see the frequency in the y-axis
across the income distributions
how about enabling the probability as
true
so that we enable the density instead of
the frequency
so now we have the density in the y-axis
and in the x-axis we still have the
income distribution
this is the way of also adding a line
plot which is a density plot
on the histogram now as you observe here
the density plot is not in the same
level as the bar so let us adjust this
line
for this we will include
adjust
let's say equal to 3 and now let us see
how the visualization appears now the
density plot is on the same level as the
bar
now let us see how to create a cross
table
for car category
and gender
for this let us call the library descr
now let us create the visualization
enabling cross table for car category
and
gender
let's look at the result in console
as you see here now we see the counts of
the gender for individual car category
the values over here represents that
there are 67 females
falling within the car category economy
and 80 males within the car category
economy
and for luxury we see that
the count of female is higher than the
male as well the proportions now how do
you understand what proportions are
presented here
we may simply turn off some of the
proportions like the t test the
chi-square etc let us see how to enable
that
now let's look at the result this looks
better
now that we have the counts the female
counts and the male counts across
individual car category we also see the
percentages
rather than just looking at the absolute
value so there are
45.6 percentage of female within the car
category economy and 54.4 percentage of
male within the car category economy
similarly across rest of the car
categories
this kind of cross table or a
contingency table is also helpful when
you want to analyze the different
categorical variables and identify the
counts or the proportions now let us see
how to use a scatter plot of age versus
income
scatter plot is a visualization used for
bivariate analysis when you want to
perform some analysis between two
continuous variable at a data point
level rather than performing the
analysis at an aggregated level such as
sum or main
and now we have a scatter plot of age
versus the income age in the x axis and
income in the y axis
though we do not see any kind of a
positive correlation or a negative
correlation but we still see some
interesting insights over here
some of the data points are pretty much
scattered and much away from densely
populated data points
i hope the learning has been informative
and interesting so far we have covered
the concepts of data analytics as well
we have performed some hands-on doing
some statistical analysis and also
creating interesting visualization
now
we have shruti who will tell us the top
10 data analysis tools and help us
understand data analytics jobs resume
salary career skills roles and
responsibilities
finally she will help you learn the
difference between a data scientist and
a data analyst
over to sruti now
to achieve the goals of data analysis we
use a number of data analysis tools
companies rely on these tools to gather
and transform their data into meaningful
insights so which tool should you choose
to analyze your data which tool should
you learn if you want to make a career
in this field we will answer that in
this session
after extensive research we have come up
with these top 10 data analysis tools
here we will look at the features of
each of these tools and the companies
using them so let's start
off at number 10 we have microsoft excel
all of us would have used microsoft
excel at some point right it is easy to
use and one of the best tools for data
analysis developed by microsoft excel is
basically a spreadsheet program
using excel you can create grids of
numbers text and formulae it is one of
the widely used tools be it in a small
or large setup
the interface of microsoft excel looks
like this
let's now move on to the features of
excel
firstly excel works with almost every
other piece of software in office we can
easily add excel spreadsheets to word
documents and powerpoint presentations
to create more visually appealing
reports or presentations
the windows version of excel supports
programming through microsoft's visual
basic for applications vba
programming with vba allows spreadsheet
manipulation that is difficult with
standard spreadsheet techniques
in addition to this the user can
automate tasks such as formatting or
date organization in vba
one of the biggest benefits of excel is
its ability to organize large amounts of
data into orderly logical spreadsheets
and charts
by doing so it's a lot easier to analyze
data especially while creating graphs
and other visual data representations
the visualization can be generated from
specified group of cells
those were few of the features of
microsoft excel
let's now have a look at the companies
using it most of the organizations today
use excel few of them that use it for
analysis are the uk based company ernest
and young then we have urban pro wipro
and amazon
moving on to our next data analysis tool
at number nine we have rapidminer
a data science software platform
rapidminer provides an integrated
environment for data preparation
analysis machine learning and deep
learning
it is used in almost every business and
commercial sector rapidminer also
supports all the steps of the machine
learning process
seen on your screens is the interface of
rapidminer
moving on to the features of rapidminer
firstly it offers the ability to drag
and drop it is very convenient to just
drag drop some columns as you are
exploring a data set and working on some
analysis
rapidminer allows the usage of any data
and it also gives an opportunity to
create models which are used as a basis
for decision making and formulation of
strategies
it has data exploration features such as
graphs descriptive statistics and
visualization which allows users to get
valuable insights
it also has more than 1500 operators for
every data transformation and analysis
task
let's now have a look at the companies
using rapidminer
we have the caribbean airline leeward
islands air transport next we have the
united health group the american online
payment company paypal and the austrian
telecom company mobilecom so that was
all about rapidminer now let's see which
tour we have at number eight
we have talent at number eight
talon is an open source software
platform which offers data integration
and management it specializes in big
data integration talent is available
both in open source and premium versions
it is one of the best tools for cloud
computing and big data integration
the interface of talent is as seen on
your screens
moving on to the features of talent
firstly automation is one of the great
boons talent offers it even maintains
the tasks for the users this helps with
quick deployment and development
it also offers open source tools talon
lets you download these tools for free
the development costs reduce
significantly as the processes gradually
speed up
talent provides a unified platform it
allows you to integrate with many
databases sas and other technologies
with the help of the data integration
platform you can build flat files
relational databases and cloud apps 10
times faster
those were the features of talon the
companies using talent are air france
l'oreal capgemini and the american
multinational pisa restaurant chain
dominos
next on the list at seven we have nine
constance information miner on nime is a
free and open source data analytics
reporting and integration platform
it can integrate various components for
machine learning and data mining through
its modular data pipelining concept
nime has been used in pharmaceutical
research and other areas like crm
customer data analysis business
intelligence text mining and financial
data analysis
here is how the interface of nime
application looks like
now coming to the 9 features
9 provides an interactive graphical user
interface to create visual workflows
using the drag and drop feature
use of jdbc allows assembly of nodes
blending different data sources
including pre-processing such as etl
that is extraction transformation
loading for modeling data analysis and
visualization with minimal programming
it supports multi-threaded in-memory
data processing 9 allows users to
visually create data flows selectively
execute some or all analysis steps and
later inspect the results models and
interactive views
9 server automates workflow execution
and supports team-based collaboration
nime integrates various other open
source projects such as machine learning
algorithms from becca hedge-to-world
keras park and our project
nime allows analysis of 300 million
custom addresses 20 million cell images
and 10 million molecular structures
some of the companies hiring for nime
are united health group asml fractal
analytics atos and lego group
let's now move on to the next tool we
have sas at number six
sas facilitates analysis reporting and
predictive modeling with the help of
powerful visualizations and dashboards
in sas data is extracted and categorized
which helps in identifying and analyzing
data patterns
as you can see on your screens this is
how the interface looks like
moving on to the features of sas
using sas better analysis of data is
achieved by using automatic code
generation as a sql
sas allows you to access through
microsoft office by letting you create
reports using it and by distributing
them through it
sas helps with an easy understanding of
complex data and allows you to create
interactive dashboards and reports
let's now have a look at the companies
using sas we have companies like gen
pact iqea accenture and ibm to name a
few
that was all about sas
so for all those who joined in late let
me just quickly repeat our list at
number 10 we have microsoft excel then
at number nine we have rapidminer at
number eight we have talent at number
seven we have nine and at number six we
have sas so far do you all agree with
this list let us know in the comment
section below let's now move on to the
next 5 tools in our list
so at number 5 we have both r and python
yes we have two of them in the fifth
position
r is a programming language which is
used for analysis as well it has
traditionally been used in academics and
research
python is a high level programming
language which has a python data
analysis library it is used for
everything starting from importing data
from excel spreadsheets to processing
them for analysis
this is the interface of r
next up is the interface of the python
jupyter notebook
let's now move on to the features of
both r and python
when it comes to the availability of r
and python it is very easy both r and
python are completely free hence it can
be used without any license
r used to compute everything in memory
and hence the computations were limited
but now it has changed both are in
python have options for parallel
computations and good data handling
capabilities
as mentioned earlier as both r and
python are open in nature all the latest
features are available without any delay
moving on to the companies using r we
have uber google facebook to name a few
python is used by many companies again
to name a few we have amazon google and
the american photo and video sharing
social networking service instagram
that was all about rn python
at number four we have apache spark
apache spark is an open source engine
developed specifically for handling
large-scale data processing and
analytics
spark offers the ability to access data
in a variety of sources including hadoop
distributed file system htfs openstack
swift
amazon s3 and cassandra
it allows you to store and process data
in real time across various clusters of
computers using simple programming
constructs
apache spark is designed to accelerate
analytics on hadoop while providing a
complete suite of complementary tools
that include a fully featured machine
learning library a graph processing
engine and stream processing
so this is how the interface of apache
spark looks like
now let's look at the important features
of apache spark
spark stores data in the ram hence it
can access the data quickly and
accelerate the speed of analytics spark
helps to run an application in a hadoop
cluster up to 100 times faster in memory
and 10 times faster when running on disk
it supports multiple languages and
allows the developers to write
applications in java scala r or python
spark comes up with 80 high level
operators for interactive querying
sparkcore for batch processing joins
stream against historical data or run ad
hoc queries on stream state
analytics can be performed better as
spark has a rich set of sql queries
machine learning algorithms complex
analytics etc apache spark provides
fault tolerance through spark rdd spark
resilient distributed data sets are
designed to handle the failure of any
worker node in the cluster thus it
ensures that the loss of data reduces to
zero
conviva netflix iqea lockheed martin and
ebay are some of the companies that use
apache spark on a daily basis
at number 3 we have another important
growing data analysis tool that is click
view
click view software is a product of
click for business intelligence and data
visualization qlikview is a business
discovery platform that provides
self-service bi for all business users
and organizations
with qlikview you can analyze data and
use your data discoveries to support
decision making
clickview is a leading business
intelligence and analytics platform in
gartner magic quadrant
on the screen you can see how the
interface of click view looks like
now talking about its features
clickview provides interactive guided
analytics with in-memory storage
technology during the process of data
discovery and interpretation of
collected data the qlikview software
helps the user by suggesting possible
interpretations
clickview uses a new patent in memory
architecture for data storage all the
data from the different sources is
loaded in the ram of the system and it
is ready to be retrieved from there
it has the capability of efficient
social and mobile data discovery
social data discovery offers to share
individual data insights within groups
or out of it
a user can add annotations as an
addition to someone else's insights on a
particular data report qlikview supports
mobile data discovery within an html5
enabled touch feature which lets the
user search the data and conduct data
discovery interactively and explore
other server-based applications
qlikview performs olap and etl features
to perform analytical operations extract
data from multiple sources transform it
for usage and load it to a data
warehouse
the companies that can help you start
your career in qlikview are
mercedes-benz cab gemini citibank
cognizant and accenture to name a few
at number two we have power bi
power bi is a business analytics
solution that lets you visualize your
data and share insights across your
organization or embed them in your app
or website
can connect to hundreds of data sources
and bring your data to life with live
dashboards and reports
power bi is the collective name for a
combination of cloud-based apps and
services that help organizations collate
manage and analyze data from a variety
of sources through a user-friendly
interface
power bi is built on the foundation of
microsoft excel and has several
components such as windows desktop
application called power bi desktop an
online software is a service called
power bi service mobile power bi apps
available on windows phones and tablets
as well as for ios and android devices
here is how the power bi interface looks
like as you can see there is a visually
interactive sales report with different
charts and graphs
moving on to the features of power bi
it has an easy drag and drop
functionality with features that make
data visually appealing you can create
reports without having the knowledge of
any programming language
power bi helps users see not only what's
happened in the past and what's
happening in the present but also what
might happen in the future
it offers a wide range of detailed and
attractive visualizations to create
reports and dashboards you can select
several charts and graphs from the
visualization pane power bi has machine
learning capabilities with which it can
spot patterns in data and use those
patterns to make informed predictions
and run what-if scenarios
power bi supports multiple data sources
such as excel tech csv oracle sql server
pdf and xml files the platform
integrates with other popular business
management tools like sharepoint office
365 and dynamics 365 as well as other
non-microsoft products like spark hadoop
google analytics sap sales force and
mailchimp
some of the companies using power bi are
adobe axa carlsberg capgemini and nestle
moving on to the next tool so any
guesses as to what we have at number one
you can comment in the chat section
below
finally on the top of the pyramid we
have tableau
gartner's magic quadrant of 2020
classified tableau as a leader in
business intelligence and data analysis
tableau interactive data visualization
software company was founded in jam 2003
in mountain view california
tableau is a data visualization software
that is used for data science and
business intelligence it can create a
wide range of different visualization to
interactively present the data and
showcase insights
the important products of tableau are
tableau desktop tableau public tableau
server tableau online and tableau reader
this is how the interface of tableau
desktop looks like
now coming to the features of tableau
data analysis is very fast with tableau
and the visualizations created are in
the form of dashboards and worksheets
tableau delivers interactive dashboards
that support insights on the fly
it can translate queries to
visualizations and import all ranges and
sizes of data writing simple sql queries
can help join multiple data sets and
then build reports out of it you can
create transparent filters parameters
and highlighters
tableau allows you to ask questions spot
trends and identify opportunities with
the help of tableau online you can
connect with cloud databases amazon
redshift and google bigquery
the companies using tableau are deloitte
adobe
cisco linkedin and the american
e-commerce giant amazon to name a few
and there you go those are the top 10
data analysis tools
hello everyone we have an interesting
topic for today and that is data
analytics jobs career and salary i will
run you through the top 6 data analytics
job roles so before i dive deep into the
various job rules let's quickly
understand how important a career in
data analytics is and what the future
holds for professionals in this domain
let's take a look at the growth of data
so back in the early 2000s there was
relatively less data generated but with
a rapid rise in technologies and with
the increase in the number of various
social media platforms and multinational
companies across the globe the
generation of data has increased by
leaps and bounds
did you know that according to the idc
the total volume of data is expected to
reach 175 zettabytes in 2025
now that's a lot of data let's take a
look at how organizations leverage all
of this data
as you know there are zillions of
companies across the world these
companies generate loads of data on a
daily basis when i say data here it
simply refers to business information
customer data customer feedback product
innovations sales reports and profit
loss reports to name a few
companies utilize all of this data in a
wise way they use all of this
information to make crucial decisions
that can either hamper or boost their
businesses
you might have heard of the term data is
the new oil well it definitely is but
only if organizations analyze all the
available data very well then this oil
is definitely valuable
and for that we have data analytics
organizations take the help of data
analytics to convert the available raw
data into meaningful insights
so what is data analytics technically
you can say it is a process wherein data
is collected from various sources then
cleaned which involves removing
irrelevant information and then finally
transformed into some meaningful
information that can be interpreted by
humans
various technologies tools and
frameworks are used in the analysis
process
as you might have heard of the term data
never sleeps well it surely doesn't
every millisecond some of the other data
is generated and this is a constant
process this process is only going to
increase in the near future with the
advent of newer technologies the data
analytics domain holds paramount
importance in every sector
companies want to leverage on all the
generated big data and boost their
businesses
they need professionals who can play
with data and convert them into crucial
insights organizations are constantly on
the lookout for such candidates and this
opportunity will only increase as data
is only going to grow every second
so if you want to start your career in
this field or if you want to switch your
job role into a role in the data
analytics domain then we have a set of
job profiles that you can look at
we will look into six job roles in the
data analytics field and learn what each
job role is all about the
responsibilities of a professional
working in that particular role the
skills required to get that particular
job the average annual salary of a
professional working in that role and
finally the company is hiring for that
role so let's start off
first we have the job role of a data
analyst
a data analyst is a person who collects
processes and performs statistical
analysis of large data sets every
business generates and collects data be
it marketing research sales figures
logistics or transportation costs a data
analyst will take this data and figure
out a variety of measures such as how to
price new materials how to reduce
transportation costs or how to deal with
issues that cost the company money they
deal with data handling data modeling
and reporting
now talking about their responsibilities
data and lists recognize and understand
the organization's goal they collaborate
with different team members such as
programmers business analysts engineers
and data scientists to identify
opportunities for solving business
problems
data analysts write complex sql queries
scripts and store procedures to gather
and extract information from multiple
databases
they filter and clean data using
different modern tools and techniques
and make it ready for analysis they also
perform data mining from primary and
secondary data sources
data analysts identify analyze and
interpret trends in complex data sets
this is done using statistical tools
such as r and sas
another key responsibility of a data
analyst is to create summary reports and
build various data visualizations for
decision making and presenting it to the
stakeholders
next let us discuss the important skills
that you need to know to become a data
analyst
firstly you should have a bachelor's
degree in computer science or
information technology a master's degree
in computer applications or statistics
is also preferable
you must have a good understanding of
programming languages like r python
javascript and also understand sql
in addition to that it is beneficial if
you have hands-on experience with
statistical and data analytics tools
such as sas minor microsoft excel and
ssas
basic understanding of machine learning
and its algorithms would be an advantage
acquaint yourself with descriptive
predictive prescriptive and inferential
statistics
most importantly you need to have a good
working knowledge of various data
visualization software along with
presentation skills this will help you
pitch in your ideas and viewpoints to
the clients and stakeholders better
now talking about their salaries a data
analyst earns nearly 5 lakhs 23 000
rupees per annum in india while in the
united states they earn around 62
453 dollars per annum
let's now look at a few of the companies
hiring data analysts so as you can see
we have the american e-commerce joint
amazon then we have microsoft the
american online payment company paypal
then we have walmart bloomberg and
capital one so that was all about data
analyst
the next job role is of a business
business analysts help guide businesses
in improving products services and
software through data driven solutions
they are responsible for bridging the
gap between it and business using data
analytics to evaluate processes
determine requirements and deliver
data-driven recommendations and reports
to executives and stakeholders
business analysts are responsible for
creating new models that support
business decisions and come up with
initiatives and strategies to optimize
costs
now let us look at the various
responsibilities of a business analyst
business analysts have a good
understanding of the requirements for
business their vital role is to work in
accordance with relevant project
stakeholders to understand their
requirements and translate them into
details which the developers can
understand
they frequently interact with developers
and come up with a plan to design the
layout of a software application
they also run meetings with stakeholders
and other authorities they engage with
business leaders and users to understand
how data driven changes to products
services software and hardware can
improve efficiencies and add value
they ensure that the project is running
smoothly as per the requirements and the
design planned through user acceptance
and validation testing
they make sure all the features are
being incorporated into the application
bas rely on different software to write
documentation and design visualization
to explain all the findings it is
extremely critical for any ba to
effectively document the findings where
each requirement of the client is
mentioned in detail
now let us look at the skills required
for a ba
a bachelor's degree in the field of
science engineering or statistics or any
related domain will suffice
knowledge of programming languages such
as python and java is beneficial you
should be really good at writing complex
sql queries and you should also have
knowledge of various business process
models
along with knowledge of programming
languages ideas about statistical
analysis and predictive modelling is
necessary
decision making strong analytical and
problem solving skills are necessary to
solve software and business issues you
also need to have excellent presentation
and communication skills both oral and
written
moving on to their salary a business
analyst is expected to earn around seven
lakh rupees per annum in india in the us
they earn nearly sixty eight thousand
three forty six dollars per annum
iqea dell philips honeywell the famous
american messaging platform whatsapp the
uk based company ernest and young are
few of the companies hiring for business
analysts
up next we have the job role of a
database administrator
a database administrator is a
specialized computer systems
administrator who maintains a successful
database environment by directing or
performing all related activities to
keep the organization's data secure
they are responsible for storing
organizing and retrieving data from
several databases and data warehouses
their top responsibility is to maintain
data integrity this means that database
administrator will ensure that the data
is secure from unauthorized access
moving on to their responsibilities
a database administrator develops
designs and maintains a database to
ensure that the data in it is properly
stored organized and managed well
they maintain data integrity by avoiding
unauthorized access and they keep
databases up to date
they run tests and modify the existing
databases to ensure that they operate
reliably they also inform end users of
changes in databases and train them to
utilize systems
they need to cooperate with programmers
data analysts and the it staffs to
ensure smooth running and maintenance of
databases
database administrators are responsible
for taking system backups in case of
power outages and other disasters so
they should have an efficient disaster
recovery plan
now let's have a look at their skills
to become a database administrator you
should have a bachelor's degree in
computer science or information
technology
knowledge of programming languages such
as python java and scala is important
you need to carry at least three to five
years of experience in data management
you need to have an understanding of
different databases such as oracle db
mongodb mysql server and posgress sql
also they should have an idea about
database design and writing sql queries
finally you need to have a good
understanding of operating systems such
as windows mac os and linux along with
storage technologies
talking about their salary a database
administrator in india can earn up to 4
lakh 97 000 rupees per annum in the us
they earn around 78 000 dollars per
annum
let's have a look at the companies
hiring for database administrators
so as you see here we have bookmyshow
oracle the american mnc intel amazon
robert half and the new york times to
name a few
fourth in the list of job roles we have
data engineer
a data engineer someone who's involved
in preparing data for analytical and
operational uses a data engineer
transforms data into useful format for
analysis
they build and test scalable big data
ecosystems for businesses
a data engineer is an intermediary
between a data analyst and a data
scientist
now let's jump into their
responsibilities
data engineers develop test and maintain
architectures they are responsible for
managing optimizing and monitoring data
retrieval storage and distribution
throughout the organization
they discover opportunities for data
acquisition find trends in data sets and
develop algorithms to help make raw data
more useful to the enterprise
data engineers build large data
warehouses using etl for storing and
retrieving data
they also recommend ways to improve data
quality and efficiency along with
building algorithms to help give easier
access to raw data
data engineers often work with big data
and submit their reports to data
scientists for analysis purpose they
need to recommend and sometimes
implement ways to improve data
reliability efficiency and quality
moving on to the skills of a data
engineer a data engineer should hold a
bachelor's degree in computer science or
information technology
they should have good hands-on
experience with python r and java
also data engineers should be well
well-versed with big data technologies
such as hadoop apache spark scala
cassandra and mongodb
data warehousing and detail experience
are essential to this position along
with in-depth knowledge of sql and other
database solutions
basic knowledge of statistical analysis
will be an advantage along with idea
about operating systems
here is what a data engineer can earn so
in india a data engineer can earn up to
eight lakhs eighty-five thousand rupees
per annum while they can earn around
hundred and three thousand dollars a
year in the usa
we have cab gemini shutterstock the
american provider of stock photography
spotify accenture genpak and facebook
hiring data engineers
the next exciting job role is of a data
scientist
a data scientist is a professional who
uses statistical methods data analysis
techniques machine learning and related
concepts in order to understand and
analyze data to draw business
conclusions
they make sense to messy and
unstructured data and bring value out of
it
they employ techniques and theories
drawn from many fields within the
context of mathematics statistics
computer science and information science
a data scientist understands the
challenges in business and comes up with
the best solutions using modern tools
and techniques to analyze visualize and
build prediction models to make business
decisions
let us now look at their
responsibilities in the industries
data scientists clean process and
manipulate data using several data
analytics tools they perform ad hoc data
mining collect large sets of structured
and unstructured data from disparate
sources
they design and evaluate advanced
statistical models to work on big data
they also create automated anomaly
detection systems and keep constant
track of their performance
data scientists interpret the analysis
of big data to discover solutions and
opportunities
a data scientist takes input from data
analysts and engineers to formulate the
results
use visualization packages and tools to
create reports and dashboards for
relevant stakeholders they also adopt
new business models and approaches
apart from this they regularly build
predictive models and machine learning
algorithms
now moving on to the skills of a data
scientist
a bachelor's degree in computer science
or information technology will be fine
but a master's degree in the field of
data science will hold a major advantage
you also need to have a good experience
in the analytics domain
you should be proficient in programming
languages such as python java and c plus
knowledge of perl will also be an
advantage
familiarity with apache hive big and
apache spark is necessary along with the
knowledge of hadoop
in addition to knowing programming
languages you also need to know sql
machine learning and deep learning
data visualization and bi skills are
necessary for creating reports and
dashboards you should also be able to
communicate and present information and
ideas properly
now talking about their salary a data
scientist in india can expect an annual
salary of 10 lakhs 47 000 rupees per
year
meanwhile in the us they can earn up to
113 000 dollars per annum that's a lot
of money
from the many companies hiring for data
scientists here we have a few companies
named they are yet again amazon citibank
apple google the japanese electronic
commerce and online retailing company
rakuten and facebook
and finally we have machine learning
engineer
machine learning engineers are
professionals who develop intelligent
machines that can learn from vast
amounts of data and apply knowledge
without human intervention
they use different algorithms and
statistical modeling to make sense of
data they design and develop machine
learning and deep learning algorithms
their main goal is to create
self-running
software let's have a look at the
responsibilities of a machine learning
engineer
machine learning engineers research
design and develop machine learning
systems they use exceptional
mathematical skills in order to perform
faster computations and work with
algorithms to create sophisticated
models
they perform a b testing and use data
modeling to fine-tune the results
they use data modeling and evaluation
strategy to find hidden patterns and
predict unseen instances
machine learning engineers work closely
with data engineers to build data
pipelines and interact with stakeholders
to get a clarity on the requirements
most importantly they analyze complex
data sets to verify data quality perform
model tests and experiments choose to
implement the right machine learning
algorithm and select the right training
data sets
moving on to their skills
a machine learning engineer should have
a degree in computer science and
information technology they should have
an advanced degree in computer science
or maths
in addition to this they should also
have experience in the same domain
they should be proficient in programming
languages such as python r c plus plus
and java
knowledge of statistics probability and
linear algebra is necessary as all the
machine learning algorithms have been
derived from mathematics also having an
idea of signal processing would be
beneficial
machine learning engineers need to have
a good understanding of data
manipulation and machine learning
libraries such as numpy panda
scikit-learn etc
they should have good oral and written
communication skills
let us now have a look at their salary
structure
a machine learning engineer earns 8 lakh
rupees per annum in india
while in the us they can earn around 114
a year now that's a whopping amount
isn't it
let's have a look at the companies
hiring machine learning engineers
so as you see we have amazon microsoft
oracle salesforce rapido and accenture
to name a few
that was all about the job role of a
machine learning engineer
now that we have seen the different job
roles in the field of data analytics
let's also go ahead and see how an ideal
resume of a data analyst should look
like
seen on your screens is a sample resume
of a data analyst you can grab some
ideas from this and incorporate them in
your resume
nowadays it's quite common to have a
professional photograph of yours on the
resume you can go ahead and have that
then your name in bold followed by your
contact details like email id and phone
number
then moving on you would have to write a
summary briefly explain your current job
role and what you're looking for in the
future
having a linkedin profile link works
well these days employers can just go
ahead and look at your profile and gauge
you well
make sure to have an active linkedin
profile
in addition to linkedin profile it's
also good to have a github profile link
which can show your coding or other
technical skills
if it's impressive enough then a lot of
times the rest of your resume is just
secondary
as i mentioned this is a resume of a
data analyst so as you can see in the
summary here we have just spoken about
the basic responsibilities of a data
analyst
moving on to the experience part you
have to write the job title and below
that you can mention the company and the
tenure accordingly here you would have
to give a brief description of
achievements in the organization any
relevant accomplishments related to the
job you're applying for the tools and
the various technologies you have worked
with
so in the sample you can see we have
spoken about data visualization using r
and tableau next we have spoken about
how the candidate has worked with other
teams for a better business outcome
most of the data and lists use sql and
excel to handle data for reporting and
database maintenance and we have
mentioned that here as well
do make sure that you always specify the
tools you use
then you can also mention if you have
worked on improving data delivery for
example here we have spoken about
developing and optimizing sql queries
data aggregations and etl to improve
data delivery
finally you can speak a bit about your
reporting skills and if needed elaborate
on it
usually professionals would have worked
in a similar domain before becoming a
data analyst
here we have taken the role of a
statistical assistant as the first job
since it's easier for a candidate with
this job role to shift into the data
analytics field nevertheless y'all can
still mention your prior experience here
be it in any domain
under the responsibilities for this job
role we have given basics such as coding
data prior to computer entry compiling
statistics from various reports
computing and analyzing data and find me
some visualization and reporting
moving to the education
here you can mention the name of your
degree and the university name if you
have a post graduation well and good you
can list both the degrees here also if
you have any certifications you can
mention them here under the education
category
now moving to the skills depending on
your skills and your choice you can
either shift this part to the beginning
of the resume or have it here as you see
on your screens this is just a different
way of displaying your skill sets you
can have all the five stars colored if
you are excellent in that particular
tool or language
as you see it's crystal clear as to what
the candidate's strong areas are
you can have various categories like
shown
for example under software development
you can list the languages that you know
and how proficient you are in those
particular languages
it's clear that the candidate knows
python better than javascript here so
the employer gets a clear idea about the
skills you possess and the depth of it
similarly you can mention the databases
as well
the few mentioned here are more or less
a requirement to become a data analyst
at least sql is a must
not to forget data visualization is also
very important when it comes to the job
role of a data analyst mention the tools
you know here and similarly give
yourself a rating out of five
five stars shaded being the highest
here we have mentioned tableau and excel
which are more than sufficient to become
a data analyst
moving to the non-technical skills you
can mention the languages you know here
here we have taken english and german in
addition to the languages you can also
feel free to mention the extracurricular
activities that you are good at
so this is how an ideal resume of a data
analyst should look like you can alter
it according to your achievements skills
and experience
hello everyone we have an exciting topic
for today and that is data scientist
versus data analyst
currently all of us are living in an
information driven world and
organizations rely on data for various
decision makings this in turn provides a
lot of job opportunities for candidates
who can play with data out of the many
job roles in the field of data science
the two popular ones are that of a data
scientist and a data analyst
haven't we all wondered at some point as
to what the exact difference is between
these two job roles oh wait are they the
same
well they differ in various ways and you
will see how in this video
we will start off by looking at the job
descriptions of both the data scientist
and the data analyst then we will look
at their responsibilities and skill set
we will also have a look at their salary
structure and the various companies
hiring for these professionals so
without further ado let's get started
let's have a look at the job description
now
a data scientist is a professional who
uses different statistical methods data
analysis techniques and machine learning
in order to understand and analyze data
in order to arrive at business
conclusions
they proactively fetch information from
a plethora of sources and analyze it for
better understanding about how the
business performs and they also build ai
tools that automate certain processes
within the company
they derive meaning out of messy and
unstructured data a data scientist is
usually a senior most member in the team
moving to the description of data
analyst a data analyst is responsible to
collect process and perform analysis on
large data sets
they deal with data handling data
modeling and reporting
they are sometimes the entry-level
members into the data analytics team
they bring technical expertise to ensure
the quality and accuracy of the data
then process design and present it in
ways to help people businesses and
organizations make better decisions
after a few years of experience data
analysts can move into the roles of a
data engineer and a data scientist
now that we have understood the job
descriptions let's go ahead and
understand the various roles and
responsibilities of a data scientist and
a data analyst
firstly data scientists are responsible
for performing cleaning processing and
manipulation of data using several data
analytics tools
they also perform ad hoc data mining and
collect large sets of structured and
unstructured data from a number of
sources
secondly data scientists interpret the
data using various statistical methods
they design and evaluate advanced
statistical models to work on big data
thirdly data scientists regularly build
predictive models and machine learning
algorithms to work on vast volumes of
data
lastly data scientists use visualization
packages and tools to create reports and
dashboards for relevant stakeholders
they also work with data analysts and
data engineers to formulate the analysis
results
let's now have a look at the various
responsibilities of a data analyst
the first responsibility of a data
analyst is to recognize and understand
the company's goal this in turn helps in
streamlining the whole analysis process
they are required to assess the
available resources comprehend the
business problem and gather the right
set of data
this step is done by collaborating with
different team members such as data
scientists business analysts and
programmers
they gather data from various databases
and warehouses through querying they
write complex sql queries and scripts to
gather and extract information
data analysts also filter and clean data
to get the required information they are
responsible for data mining as well
data is mined from various sources and
then organized in order to obtain new
information from it data and lists
identify and analyze trends in complex
data sets using various statistical
tools
a data analyst is also responsible for
creating summary reports for the
leadership team so that they can make
timely decisions
data analysts use multiple data
visualization tools for achieving this
in order to achieve all the above
mentioned responsibilities data
scientists and data analysts are
required to possess a rich skill set
let's now have a look at few of the most
important skills required to back the
position of a data scientist
the basic requirement to become a data
scientist is that you must have a
bachelor's degree in computer science or
information technology but a master's
degree in the field of data science will
be a lot more beneficial
you also need to have a good experience
in the analytics domain as i mentioned
before this role is a senior role and to
get here the right amount of experience
is a must
let's have a look at the tools you need
to know
knowledge of microsoft excel is good it
is one of the most basic requirements
speaking of programming languages you
should be good at python c plus plus and
java
knowledge of perl is a brawny point you
should also be proficient in sql
as we discussed earlier data scientists
work on building machine learning
algorithms hence you need to have a good
knowledge of machine learning and deep
learning
familiarity with apache spark apache
hive and apache pig is necessary along
with the knowledge of hadoop
data visualization and bi skills are
necessary for creating reports and
dashboards you should also be able to
communicate and present information and
ideas clearly
so these are the skills required to
become a data scientist
if you want to explore the role of a
data analyst then you should hold a
degree in any relevant field beat
engineering in computer science
information technology or electrical
engineering you can also be a graduate
in statistics or economics
moving on to the tools once again you
should be familiar with microsoft excel
the next important skill is that you
should have good hands-on experience
with programming languages such as
python r and javascript this would help
you write programs to solve complex
problems
you should also have a good knowledge of
statistical and data analytics tools
such as sas minor and ssas
you must be able to write various sql
queries and procedures
in addition to these you must have a
strong understanding of statistics and
machine learning algorithms these
include concepts such as hypothesis
testing probability distributions and
various classification and clustering
techniques
most importantly a data analyst should
be able to create visually appealing
reports with the help of charts and
graphs using several data visualization
tools such as power bi and tableau
they must possess good presentation
skills as well in order to convey their
ideas to the clients and stakeholders in
a better way
so these are the skills that are
required to become a data analyst
let's now have a look at the annual
salary range of a data scientist and a
data analyst both in the u.s and in
india
in the united states a data scientist
can earn a minimum salary of sixty one
thousand dollars to a maximum of one
hundred thirty six thousand dollars per
year
meanwhile in india a data scientist can
earn a minimum salary of three lakh
forty seven thousand rupees to a maximum
of 2 million rupees per annum
a date analyst in the united states can
earn a minimum salary of 43 000 dollars
to a maximum of 85 000 dollars per year
in india you can earn anywhere between 1
lakh 98 000 rupees to 9 lakh 24 000
rupees per annum
let's now take a look at the various
companies hiring data scientists and
data analysts
here we have amazon the internet and
search engine giant google deloitte the
american multinational technology
company microsoft then we have apple and
the american social media web and mobile
application company pinterest hiring
data scientists
from the many companies hiring data
analysts here we once again have amazon
then we have the popular retail company
walmart robertoff and atnt next we have
social media firms facebook and twitter
as you might have heard of the term data
never sleeps well it surely doesn't and
not only that but it also brings in a
number of job opportunities with it the
job group in this domain is limitless
and data will only continue to grow
let's have a look at few of the stats
now
well ibm had predicted that by this year
that is 2020 the number of job listings
in the field of data science and
analytics will increase by 3 lakh 64
000.
and we had the u.s bureau of labor
statistics predicting that there will be
a rise in the data science needs and
this in turn will create 11.5 million
job openings by 2026. now that's a big
number isn't it
and if you are aspiring to become a data
scientist then you are on the right path
as there is a huge demand for this role
according to deloitte the united states
is projected to face a shortfall of 2
lakh 50 000 data scientists by 2024
that's barely just in four more years
all these stats prove that the job
demand in the field of data science and
data analytics is here to stay
professionals belonging to this domain
are in high demand all across the globe
now let's have a look at the google
search trends for data scientists and
data analysts
as you see the blue color depicts data
scientists and the red data analysts
both the search trends go hand in hand
and over time the search term data
analyst is higher but the search term of
that of a data scientist is experiencing
a steady rise
let's have a look at the worldwide
youtube search trend as well
as you can see on your screens it looks
like people are more keen on exploring
the job role of a data scientist and
looks like they want to learn more about
the job role of a data scientist
compared to that of a data analyst
nevertheless the search term data
analyst is also right there in the
competition
now richard will help us understand the
top data and list interview questions
today we're going to jump into some
common questions you might see on numpy
arrays and pandas data frames and the
python along with some excel tabloo and
sql
let's start with our first question what
is the difference between data mining
and data profiling
it's real important to note that data
mining is a process of finding relevant
information which has not been found
before it is a way in which raw data is
turned into valuable information
you can think of this as anything from
the cells
stats and from their sql server all the
way to web scraping and census bureau
information where the heck do you mine
it from where do you get all this data
and information
then we look at data profiling is
usually done to assess a data set for
its uniqueness consistency and logic it
cannot identify incorrect or inaccurate
data values
so if somebody has a statistical
analysis on one side and they're doing
their you might in the wrong data to
then program your data set up so you got
to be aware that when you're talking
about data mining you need to look at
the integrity of what you're bringing in
where it's coming from data profiling is
looking at it and saying hey how is this
going to work what's the logic what's
the consistency is it related to what
i'm working with
find the term data wrangling and data
analytics
data wrangling is a process of cleaning
structuring and enriching the raw data
into a desired usable format for better
decision making
and you can see a nice chart here with
our discover it we structure the data
how we want it we clean it up get rid of
all those null values we enrich it so we
might take and reformat some of the
settings instead of having five
different terms for height of somebody
you know in american english or whatever
clean some of that up and we might do a
calculation and bring some of them
together
and validate i was just talking about
that the last one need to validate your
data make sure you have a solid data
source and then of course it goes into
the analysis
very important to notice here in data
wrangling eighty percent of data
analytics is usually in this whole part
of wrangling the data getting it to fit
correctly and don't confuse that with
data cooking which is actually when
you're going into neural networks
cooking the data so it's all be lit
between 0 and 1 values
what are common problems that data
analysts encounter during analysis
handling duplicate and missing values
collecting the meaningful write data the
right time
making data secure and dealing with
compliance issues
handling data purging and storage
problems
again we're talking about data wrangling
here eighty percent of most jobs are in
wrangling that data and getting it in
the right format making sure it's good
data to use
number four what are the various steps
involved in any analytics project
understand the problem we may spend 80
percent doing wrangling but you better
be ready to understand the problem
because if you can't you're going to
spend all your time in the wrong
direction this is probably
the most important part of the process
everything after it falls in and then
you can come back to it
two data collection
data cleaning number three four data
exploration analysis and five interpret
the results
number five is a close second for being
the most important if you can't
interpret what you bring to the table to
your clients you're in trouble
so when this question comes up you
probably want to focus on those two
noting that the rest of it does eighty
percent of the work is in two three and
four well 1 and 5 are the most important
parts
which technical tools have you used for
analysis and presentation purposes
being a data analyst you are expected to
have knowledge of the below tools for
analysis and presentation purposes
there's a wide variety out there
sql server mysql
you have your excel your spss which is
the ibm platform tableau
python you have all these different
tools in here now certainly a lot of
jobs are going to be narrowed in on just
a few of these tools like you're not
going to have a microsoft sql server
mysql server but you better understand
how to do basic sql polls and also
understanding excel
and how the different formats for column
and how to get those set up
number six what are the best practices
for data cleaning this is really
important to remember to go through this
in detail these always come up because
80 percent of
most data analysis in cleaning the data
make a data cleaning plan by
understanding where the common errors
take place and keep communications open
identify remove duplicates before
working with the data this will lead to
an effective data analysis process
focus on the accuracy of the data
maintain the value types of data provide
mandatory constraints and set
cross-field
standardize validation
data at the point of entry so that is
less chaotic and you will be able to
ensure that all the information is
standardized leading to fewer errors on
entry
number seven how can you handle missing
values in a data set list wise deletion
in list wise deletion method entire
record is excluded from analysis if any
single value is missing sometimes we're
talking about records remember this
could be a single line in a database so
if you have
your sql comes back and you have 15
different columns
every one of those has a missing value
you might just drop it just to make it
easy because you already have enough
data to do the processing
average imputation
use the average value of the responses
from the other participants to fill in
the missing value this is really useful
and they'll ask you why these are useful
i guarantee it
if you have a whole group of data that's
collected and it doesn't have that
information in it at that point you
might average it in there regression
substitution you can use multiple
regression analysis to estimate a
missing value that kind of goes with the
average imputation input regression
model means you're just going to get
you're going to actually generate a
prediction as to what you think that
value should be for those people based
on the ones you do have
multiple imputation so we talk about
multiple inputs creates plausible values
based on the correlations for the
missing data and then average the
simulated data sets by incorporating
random errors in your predictions
what do you understand by the term
normal distribution and the second you
hear the word normal distribution should
be thinking a bell curve like we see
here normal distribution is a type of
continuous probability distribution that
is symmetric about the mean and in the
graph normal distribution will appear as
a bell curve the mean median and mode
are equal that's a quick way to know if
you have normal distribution is you can
compute mean median and mode all of them
are located at the center of the
distribution 68 of the data lies within
one standard deviation of the mean
95 of the data falls within two standard
deviations of the mean
99.7 of the data lies within three
standard deviations of the mean
what is time series analysis
time series analysis is a statistical
method that deals with ordered sequence
of values of a variable of equally
spaced time intervals time series data
on a coveted 19 cases and you can see
we're looking at by days so our space is
of days and each day goes by if we take
and graph it you can see a time series
graph always looks really nice we have
like two different in this case we have
what the united states
going over there i have to look at the
other set up in there they picked a
couple different countries
and it is it's time sensitive you know
with the next result is based on what
the last one was kova is an excellent
example of this uh anytime you do any
word analytics where you're figuring out
what someone's saying what they said
before makes a huge difference is what
they're going to say next another form
of time series analysis
10. how is joining different from
blending in tableau
so now we're going to jump into the
tableau package
data joining data joining can only be
done when the data comes from the same
source
combining two tables from the same
database or two or more worksheets from
the same excel file all the combined
tables or sheets contains common set of
dimensions and measures
data blending data blending is used when
the data is from two or more different
sources combining the oracle table with
the sql server or two sheets from excel
or combining excel sheet and oracle
table in data blending each data source
contains its own set of dimensions and
measures
how is overfitting different from
underfitting
always a good one overfitting probably
the biggest danger in data analytics
today is overfitting
model trains from the data too well
using the training set
the performance drops significantly over
the test set happens when the model
learns the noise and random fluctuations
in the training data set in detail
and again the performance drops way
below what the test set has
the model neither trains a data well nor
can generalize to new data performs
poorly both on train and the test set
happens when there is less data to build
and an accurate model and also when we
try to build a linear model with a
non-linear data
in microsoft excel a numeric value can
be treated as a text value if it
proceeds with
an apostrophe definitely not an
exclamation
if you're used to programming in python
you'll look for that hash code and not
an amber sign
and we can see here if you enter the
value 10 into a fill but you put the
apostrophe in front of it it will read
that as a text not as a number
what is the difference between count
count a count blank and count if in
excel
we can see here when we run in just
count d1 through
d23
we get 19 and you'll notice that there
is 19
numbers coming down here and so it
doesn't count the cost of each which is
a top bracket it doesn't count the blank
spaces either with the straight count
when you do a count a
you'll get the answer is 20. so now when
you do count a it counts all of them
even the title cost of each
when you do count blank we'll get three
why there's three blank fields
and finally the count if we do countif
of e1 to e23 is greater than 10
there's 11 values in there basic
counting of whatever is in your column
pretty solid on the table
there explain how vlookup works in excel
vlookup is used when you need to find
things in a table or a range by row
the syntax has four different parts to
it
we have our lookup value that's a value
you want to look up we have our table
array
the range where the lookup value is
located
column index number the column number
and range that contains the return value
and the range lookup specify true if you
want an approximate match or false if
you want an exact match of the return
value
so here we see vlookup f3
a2 to c8 2 0 for prints now they don't
show the f3 f3 is the actual
cell that prince is in that's what we're
looking at is f3 so there's your prince
he pulls in from f3
a2 to c8 is the the data we're looking
into and then number two is a column in
that data so in this case we're looking
for uh
age and we count name is one ages two
keep in mind this is excel versus a lot
of your python and programming languages
where you start at zero in excel we
always look at the cells as one two
three so two represents the age
zero
is false for having an exact match up
versus one
we don't actually need to worry about
that too much in this zero or one would
work with this example and you can see
with the angela look up again her name
would be in the f column number four
that's what the f4 stands for is where
they pulled angela from
and then you have a1 to c8 and then
we're looking at uh number three so
number three is height name being one h2
and then height three and you'll see
here pulls in her height 5.8
so we're going to run jump over to sql
how do you subset or filter data in sql
to subset or filter data in sql we use
where and having clause
you can see we have a nice table on the
left where we have the title the
director the year the duration
we want to filter the table for movies
that were directed by brad bird
why just because we want to know who
what brad bird did so we're going to do
select star you should know that the
star refers to all in this case we're
what are we going to return we're going
to return all title directory year and
duration that's what you mean by all
from movies movies being our table
where director equals brad bird and you
can see um he comes back and he did the
incredible and ratatouille
to subset or filter data sql we can also
use the where and having clause so we're
going to take a closer look at the
different ways we can filter here filter
the table for directors whose movies
have an average duration greater than
115 minutes
so there's a lot of really cool things
into this sql query and these sql
queries can get pretty crazy
select director sum duration as total
duration average duration as average
duration from movies group by director
having average duration greater than
115.
so again what are we going to return
we're going to return whatever we put in
our select which in this case is
director we're going to have total
duration and that's going to be the sum
of the duration we're going to have the
average duration average underscore
duration which is going to be the
average duration on there
and then we course go ahead and group by
director and we want to make sure we
group them by anyone that has an having
an average duration greater than 115.
these sql queries are so important
i don't know how many times your the sql
comes up and there's so many different
other languages not just mysql and not
microsoft sql in addition to that where
the sql language comes in especially
with hadoop in other areas so you really
should know your basic sql
it doesn't hurt to get that little
cheat sheet and glance over and double
check some of the different features in
sql
what is the difference between where and
having clause and sql
where
where clause works on row data in where
clause the filter occurs before any
groupings are made aggregate functions
cannot be used
so the syntax is select
your columns from table
where what the condition is
having clause works on aggregated data
having is used to filter values from a
group aggregate functions can be used
in the syntax is select column names
from table where the condition is
grouped by having a condition ordered by
column names
what is the correct syntax for reshape
function in numpy so we're going to jump
to the numpy array program
and what you come up with is you have in
this case it'd be numpy.reshape a lot of
times you do an import numpy as np
reshape and then your array and the new
shape
and you can see here as we uh as the
actual um example comes in the reshape
is a we're going to reshape it in two
comma five setups and you can see the
print out in there that prints in two
rows with five values in each one
what are the different ways to create a
data frame in pandas
well we can do it by initializing a list
so you can port your pandas as pd very
common
data equals tom 30 jerry20 angela 35.
we'll go ahead and create the data frame
and we'll say
pd.dataframe is the data columns equals
name and age so you can designate your
columns you can also it is a index in
there you should always remember that
the index
uh in this case maybe you want the index
instead of one two to be um the date
they signed up or who knows you know
whatever and you can see right there it
just generates a nice pandas data frame
with tom jerry and angela
another way you can initialize a
data frame is from dictionary you can
see here we have a dictionary where the
date equals name tom jerry angela mary
ages 20 21 1918 and if we do a dfpd
dot data frame on the data you'll get a
nice the same kind of setup you get your
name age tom jerry angela and mary
write the python code to create an
employee's data frame from the
emp.csv file and display the head and
summary of it
to create a data frame in python you
need to import the pandas library and
use the read csv function to load the
csv file and here you can see we have
import pandas as pd employees or the
data frame employees equals pd.read csv
and then you have your path to that csv
file
there's a number of settings in the read
csv where you can tell it how many rows
are the top index
you can set the columns in there
you can have skip rows there's all kinds
of things you can also go in there and
double check with your read csv but the
most basic one is just to read a basic
csv
how will you select the department and
age columns from an employee's data
frame
so we have import pandas as pd you can
see we have created our data
we will go ahead and create our
employees pd data frame on the left
and then on the right to select
department and age from the data frame
we just do employees and you put the
brackets around it now if you're just
doing one column you could do just
department but if you're doing multiple
columns you've got to have those in a
second set of brackets it's got to be a
reference with a list within the
reference
what is the criteria to say whether a
developed data model is good or not
a good model should be intuitive
insightful and self-explanatory
follow the old saying kiss keep it
simple
the model develops should be able to
easily consumed by the clients for
actionable and profitable results
so if they can't read it what good is it
a good model should easily adapt to
changes according to business
requirements
we live in quite a dynamic world
nowadays so it's pretty self-evident and
if the data gets updated the model
should be able to scale accordingly to
the new data so you have a nice data
pipeline going where when something when
you get new data coming in you don't
have to go and rewrite the whole code
what is the significance of exploratory
data analysis
exploratory data analysis is an
important step in any data analysis
process
exploratory data analysis eda helps to
understand the data better it helps you
obtain confidence in your data to a
point where you're ready to engage a
machine learning algorithm it allows you
to refine your selection of feature
variables that will be used later for
model building you can discover hidden
trends and insights from the data
how do you treat outliers in a data set
an outlier is a data point that is
distant from other similar points they
may be due to variability in the
measurement or may indicate experimental
errors
one you can drop the outlier records
pretty straightforward you can cap your
outliers data
so it doesn't go past a certain value
you can assign it a new value you can
also try a new transformation to see if
those outliers come in if you transform
it slightly differently
explain descriptive predictive and
prescriptive analytics
descriptive provides insights into the
past to answer what has happened
uses data aggregation and data mining
techniques examples an ice cream company
can analyze how much ice cream was sold
which flavors were sold and whether more
or less ice cream was sold than before
predictive understands the future to the
answer what could happen uses
statistical models and forecasting
techniques
example predicts the sale of ice creams
during the summer spring and rainy days
uh so this is always interesting because
you have your descriptive which comes in
and your businesses are always looking
to know what happened hey did we have
good sales last quarter what are we
expecting next quarter in the cells
and we have a huge jump when we do a
prescriptive
suggest various courses of action to
answer what should you do uses
optimization and simulation algorithms
to advise possible outcomes
example lower prices to increase
sell of ice creams produce more or less
quantities of certain flavor of ice
cream and we can certainly uh today's
world with the covet virus because we
had that in our earlier graph you could
see that as a descriptive what's
happened how many people have been
infected how many people have died in an
area
predictive where do we predict that to
go
um do we see it going to get worse is it
going to get better what do we predict
that we're going to need in hospital
beds
and
prescriptive what can we change in our
setup to have a better outcome
maybe if we did more social distancing
if we tracked the virus
how do these different things directly
affect the end and can we create a
better ending by changing some
underlying criteria
what are the different types of sampling
techniques used by data analysis
sampling is a statistical method to
select a subset of data from an entire
data set
population to estimate the
characteristics of the whole population
one we can do a simple random sampling
so we can just pick out 500 random
people in the united states to sample
them they call it a population in
regular data we also call that a
population
just because that's where it came from
was mainly from doing census
systematic sampling
cluster sampling
stratified sampling
and judgment or propositive sampling
then we have our systematic sampling
that's where you're doing like uh
using 1 5
10 15 20 use a very systematic approach
for pulling samples
from the setup cluster sampling
that's where we look at it we say hey
some of these things just naturally
group together if you were talking about
population which is the really a nice
way of looking at this cluster sampling
would be maybe by a zip code we're going
to do everybody's zip code and just
naturally cluster it that way
stratified sampling would be more uh
looking for shared things a group has
like income
so if you're studying something on
poverty you might look at their
naturally group people
uh based on income to begin with and
then study those individuals in the
income to find out
what kind of traits they have
and then judgmental
that is
where the
researcher very carefully selects each
member of their own group
so it's very much
based on their personal knowledge
jumping on the 26 what are the different
types of hypothesis testing
hypothesis testing is a procedure used
by statisticians and scientists to
accept or reject statistical hypothesis
we start with a hypothesis testing we
have null hypothesis and alternative
hypothesis
on the null hypothesis it states that
there is no relation between the
predictor and the outcome variables in
the population it is denoted by h naught
example there is no association between
patients
bmi and diabetes
alternative hypothesis it states there
is some relation between the predictor
and outcome variables in the population
it is denoted by h1 example there could
be an association between patients bmi
and diabetes
and that's the body mass index if you
didn't catch the bmi and you're not
medical
describe univariate bivariate and
multivariate analysis
a univariate analysis it is the simplest
form of data analysis where the data
being analyzed contains only one
variable an example of studying the
heights of players in the nba
because it's so simple it can be
described using central tendencies
dispersion
quartiles bar charts histograms pie
charts frequency distribution tables
the bivariate analysis it involves
analysis of two variables to find causes
relationships and correlations between
the variables
example analyzing sale of ice creams
based on the temperature outside
bivariate analysis can be explained
using correlation coefficients linear
regression logistic regression scatter
plots and box plots
in multivariate analysis it involves
analysis of three or more variables to
understand the relationship of each
variable with the other variables
example analyzing revenue based on
expenditure so if we have our tv ads we
have our newspaper ads our social media
ads and a revenue we can now compare all
those together
the multivert analysis can be performed
using multiple regression factor
analysis classification and regression
trees cluster analysis principle
component analysis clustering bar chart
dual axis chart
what function would you use to get the
current date and time in excel in excel
you can use the today and now function
to get the current date and time
you can see down here with the two
examples were just equals today or
equals now
using the sumifs function in excel find
the total quantity sold by sales
representatives whose names start with a
and the cost of each item they have sold
is greater than 10.
and you can see here on the left we have
our actual table and then we want to go
ahead and sum ifs so we want the e2
through e20
b2 through b20
greater than 10. and this basically is
just saying hey we're going to take
everything in the
e column
and we're going to sum it up but only
those objects where the d column is
greater than 10. that's what that means
there
is the below query correct if not how
will you rectify it
select customer id year order date as
order year from order
where order year is greater than or
equal to 2016.
and hopefully you caught it right there
uh it's in the devils in the details we
can't not use the alias name while
filtering data using the where clause
so the correct format is all the same
except for where it says where
the year
order date is greater than or equal to
versus using the order year which we
assign under the select setup
how are union intersect and accept
used in sql
the union operator is used to combine
the results of two or more select
statements
and you can see here we have select star
from region one and we're going to make
a union with select star from region two
and it basically takes both these sql
tables and combines them to form a full
new table on there so that's your union
as we bring everything together
we look at the intersect operator
returns the common records that are the
result of the two or more select
statements
so you can see here we select star from
region 1 intersect select star from
region 2
and we come up with only those records
that are shared that have the same data
in them
and hopefully you jumped ahead to the
accept the accept operator returns the
uncommon records that are the result of
two or more select statements so these
are the red two records or the records
that are not shared between the two
databases
using the product price table write
an sql query to find the record with the
fourth highest
market price
so here we have a little bit of a brain
teaser
they're always fun
and the first thing we want to do is
we're going to go ahead and i'm going to
if you look at the
script on the left
we really want the fourth one down so
we're going to select the top four from
product price but we're going to order
it by market price descending sp order
by market price ascending
so we do is we take the top
four
of the market price ascending
and that's going to give us the four
greatest values
and then we're going to reverse that
order and do descending
and we're going to take the top one of
that which is going to give us the
lowest value which would be the fourth
greatest one in the list
from the product price table find the
total and average market price for each
currency where the average market price
is greater than 100 and currency is in
the inr or the aud
so
inr or aud india rupal or australia
dollar
you can see over here the sql query if
you had trouble putting this together
you might actually do some of it in
reverse
and you can see right here where the
average market price is greater than 50.
remember we use having not where at the
end because it's part of the group so
group by currency because we want those
two currencies and we want the currency
india the inr or the aud
and
as you keep going backwards we're
actually going to be selecting the
currency the sum of the market price
as total price and the average market
price as average price so there's our
select it's going to come from the
product price which is just our table
over there and then we have where our
currency is in uh and like i said you
can put together however you want but
hopefully you got to the end there
so this question will test your
knowledge in tableau exploring the
different features of tableau and
creating a suitable graph to solve a
business problem
and of course tableau is very visual in
its use so it's very hard to test it
without actually just getting your hands
on and if you can't visualize some of
this and how to do it then you should go
back and refresh yourself
using the sample superstore data set
create a view to analyze the cells
profits and quantities sold across
different subcategories of items present
under each category so the first step is
to go ahead and load the sample
superstore data set
so make sure you know how to load the
sample the superstore data set that's
underneath either the connect button in
the upper left
or the
tableau icon up there and be able to
pull in the data set
and then once you've done that you just
drag the category and subcategory on
rows and salaries onto columns it will
result in a horizontal bar chart
so in this one we're just going to drag
profit onto color and quantity onto
label sort the sales axes in descending
order of sum and sells within each sub
category
and if you're at home doing this you'll
see that chairs under furniture category
had the highest sales and profit while
tables had the lowest profit
for office supplies subcategory binders
made the highest profit even though
storage had the highest sales under
technology category copiers made the
highest profit though it was the least
amount of sales
let's work to create a dual axis chart
in tableau to present cells and profits
across different years using sample
superstore data set
load the orders sheet from the sample
drag the ordered data field from the
dimensions onto columns and converted
into continuous month
drag cells onto rows and profits to the
right corner of the view until you see a
light green rectangle
one of those things if you haven't done
this hands-on you don't know what you're
doing you're gonna run into a bike so
you're gonna be just kind of dropping it
and wondering what happened
synchronize the right axis by right
clicking on the profit axis
and then let's finalize it by going
under the marks card change some cells
to bar and sum profit to line and adjust
the size
and then we have a nice display that we
can either print out or save and send
off to the
shareholders
let's go and do one more tableau
design a view in tableau to show
statewide cells and profits using the
sample superstore data set
in here you go ahead and drag the
country field onto the view section and
expand it to see the states
drag the states field onto size and
profit onto color
increase the size of the bubbles add a
border and a halo color states like
washington california and new york have
the highest sales and profits while
texas pennsylvania and ohio
have a good amount of sales but the
least amount of profits
we'll go ahead and skip back to python
numpy suppose there is an array
number equals np or numpy if you're
using numpy depending on how you set it
up
dot array and we just have one to nine
broken up into three groups
extract the value eight using 2d
indexing so you can see on the left we
have our import numpy as in p number
equals our np array if we print the
number we have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9.
since the value 8 is present in the
second row and first column we use the
same index position and pass it to the
array and you just have number two comma
one and you get eight and remember we're
in python so you start at zero not one
like you do in excel
always gets me if i'm working between
excel and python where i just kind of
flip and usually see excel that messes
up because i do a lot more programming
suppose there's an array that has values
0 1
all the way up to 9. how will you
display the following values from the
array one three five seven nine
uh so first of all we go ahead and
create the array uh np dot a range of 10
which goes from zero to 9 because
there's 10 numbers in it but we don't
include the 10.
we print it out the first thing you want
to do is what's going on here with 13579
well if we divide by 2 there's going to
be a remainder equal to one
and then from python remember that if
you use the percentage sign you get the
remainder on there so the remainder is
one and then you have the your numpy
array and then we just want to do
a logical statement of all values that
have a remainder of one and that
generates our nice
one three five seven nine
there are two arrays a and b stack the
arrays a and b
horizontally
boy these horizontal vertical questions
will get you every time
and in numbi we go ahead and we've
created two different arrays over here a
and b
the first one is your concatenate np dot
concatenate
a and b on axes equal one
that is the same as h stack
and uh in the back end they're still
identical they run the same that's all
hdac is a concatenate axis equals
how can you add a column to a pandas
data frame
suppose there is an imp data frame that
has information about few employees
let's add address column to that data
frame you can see in the left we have
our basic data frame you should know
your data frames very well
basically looks like an excel
spreadsheet as you come over here it's
really simple you just do df of address
equals the address once you've assigned
values to the address
using the below
given data create a pivot table to find
the total sales made by each cells
represented for each item display the
cells as a percentage of the grand total
so we're back in tableau select the
entire table range click on insert tab
and choose pivot table
select the table range and the worksheet
where you want to place the pivot table
it will return a pivot table where you
can analyze your data
drag the cell total on the values and
sales rep and item onto row labels it
will give the sum of the cells made by
each representative for each item they
have sold
and finally right click on sum of cell
total and expand show values
as to select percentage of grand total
real important just to understand what a
pivot table is we're just pivoting it
from rows and columns and switching this
direction on there
and finally we have our final pivot
table and you can see the values rolls
and sum of total sale
so we're going to go ahead and take a
product table this is off of an sql so
we're going to do some sql here
and we're going to use the product and
sales order detail table find the
products that have total units sold
greater than 1.5 million and here's our
sales order detail table so we have a
product table and a sales order detail
table two separate tables in the
database
and we're going to do is put together
the sql query we want to select
pp name
sum sod unit price as cells
and then we have our p p dot product id
from production product as pp inner join
cells dot sales order detail as sod on
pp product id equals sod.productid
groupbypp.name comma pp.productid having
a sum of saw.unitprice greater than
the 150
million there that's a mouthful and
again these sql queries they start
looking really crazy until you just
break them apart and do them step by
step
and what we're looking for is the inner
join
and how did you do the group by this
really when they know how do you do this
inner join this comes up so much in sql
how do you pull in the id from one chart
and the information from another chart
and the sum totals on that
chart how do you write a stored
procedure in sql let's create a storage
procedure to find the sum the squares
are the first n natural numbers so here
we have our formula n times n plus 1
times 2n plus one over six
and you can see from the command prompt
uh or the setup you have depending on
what your login is the command is create
procedure square sum one
declare our variable at in of integer as
begin then we're going to declare the
sum of integer
set sum equals n times n plus 1 plus 2
times n plus 1
over 6.
and then of course we can go ahead and
print those out print first cast amber
sign in or our variable
as a variable character 20 natural
numbers
print the sum of the square is cast
the
at sum as a variable character 40 end
then we do the output display the sum of
the square for first four natural
numbers we have execute square sum one
and then we're going to put in four and
you can see here where it brings up the
first four natural numbers sum of square
is 30.
write a store procedure to find the
total even number between two user given
numbers
a couple of things to note here first we
go ahead and create our procedure you
have your two different variables the n1
in two
and we go ahead and begin we're going to
declare our variable count as an integer
we're going to set count equal to 0 and
then we have while n is less than n2
we're going to begin and if n1
remainder 2 equals 0. so we're going to
divide it by 2 even number
begin we're going to set the count equal
to count plus 1 we're going to print
even number
plus cast in as a variable
character 10 for printing count is plus
cast variable count as variable
character 10 end else print odd number
plus cast variable number one is
variable character 10. and then we go
ahead and set the
increment our variable one up one so
that goes from n
one all the way to n two and i'll print
the total number of even numbers
and you can see here we went ahead and
executed it we're going to count the
even numbers between 30 and 45 and you
see it goes all the way down to 8.
what is the difference between tree maps
and heat maps in tableau
now if you've worked in python other
programmings you should automatically
know what a heat map is
but a tree map are used to display data
in nested rectangles
you use dimensions to define the
structure of the tree map and measure to
define the size or color of individual
rectangles
tree maps are relatively simple data
visualization that can provide insight
in a visually attractive format
and again you can see the squares over
here this is our tree map over here with
the each block also has this information
inside of its different blocks
a heat map helps to visualize measures
against dimensions with the help of
colors and size to compare one or more
dimensions and up to two measures
the layout is similar to a text table
with variations in values encoded as
colors in heat map you can quickly see a
wide array of information
and in this one
you can see they use the colors to
denote one thing and the size of the
little square to denote something else
a lot of times you can even graph this
into a three-dimensional graph with
other data
so it pops out but again a heat map is
the color and the size
using the sample super stored data set
display the top five and bottom five
customers based on their profit so you
start by dragging the customer name
field onto rows and profit on columns
right click on the customer name column
to create a set
give a name to the set and select top
tab to choose top 5 customers by some
profit
similarly create a set for the bottom
five customers by some profit
select both the sets right click to
create a combined set
give a name to the set and choose all
members in both sets
and then you can drag top and bottom
customer sets onto the filters and
profit field onto color to get the
desired results
as we get down to the end of our list
we're going to try to keep you
on your toes we're going to skip back to
numpy how to print 4 random integers
between 1 and 15 using numpy to generate
random numbers using numpy we use the
random random integer function
and you see here we did the import numpy
as in p random arrangement equals
np.random.random integer
1 through 15 of 4.
from the below data frame can jump again
on you now we're into pandas
how will you find the unique values for
each column and subset the data for age
less than 35 and height greater than 6.
to find the unique values and the number
of unique elements use the unique and
the in unique function
you see here we just did df heights
we're selecting just the height column
and we want to look for the unique that
returns an array where in unique if we
do that on the height or the age will
return just the number of unique values
and then we can do a subset the data for
ages less than 35 and height greater
than six
so if we look over here we have a new df
remember this is going to be taking
slices of our original data frame it
doesn't actually change the data frame
so our new df equals the data frame or
df
the data frame where age is less than 35
and the height is greater than 6.
and in case you're not using tableau
which has a lot of its own
different mapping programs in there make
sure you understand how to use the
basics of matplot library plot a sine
graph using numpy and matplot library in
python and the way we did this is we
went ahead and generate an x we know our
y equals np.sine of x if you print out x
you'll see a whole value here our
matplot library pi plot as plt
if you are working in jupiter notebook
make sure you understand the matplot
library inline that little percentage
sign matplot library inline that prints
it on the page in the jupyter notebook
the newer version of jupyter notebook or
jupyter labs automatically does that for
you but i usually put it in there just
in case i end up on an older version
if you print y you can see here we have
our different y values and our different
x values
you simply put in plt dot plot x y and
do a plot show
and before we go let's get one more in
we're going to do a pandas using the
below pandas data frame find the company
with the highest average cells derive
the summary statistics for the cells
column and transpose these statistics
that's a mouthful and just like any of
these computer problems break it apart
so first of all we're looking for the
highest average cells so group the
company
column and use the mean function to find
the average cells
you see here by company equals df.group
by company
once we've done that using the describe
function we can now go ahead and look at
the summary of statistics on here
use the describe function to find the
summary
so by company those are groups we're
just going to describe them and you
could actually bundle those together if
you wanted and just do them all in one
line
so here we go by company.describe
you can see we have a nice breakout
always good to remember whether you're
using any of the packages whether it's
tableau or
pandas in python or even r or some other
package being able to quick look and
describe your data is very important
and then we go ahead and just do a basic
apply a transpose function over the
describe method to transpose the
statistics
all we've done here is flip the index
with the column names but if you're
following the numbers a lot of times
it's easier to follow across one line or
maybe you want to average out the count
or it's all kinds of different reasons
to do that
with that
we have come to the end of this video
tutorial on data analytics full course i
hope it was interesting and informative
if you have any questions then please
put it in the comments section of the
video don't forget to subscribe to our
youtube channel thanks for watching stay
safe and keep learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here